Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin Leute!
Windows Sound?
Jawohl, passt.
Es ist ja auch selten, dass das passt mit dem Windows Sound.
Meistens hat es irgendwas rumgestellt,
ohne dass man halt wirklich was dran rumgestellt hat.
Äh.
Das wollte ich eigentlich jetzt gar nicht aufmachen.
Keine Ahnung.
Whatever.
Kann das aufhören, irgendwelche Sachen zu laden?
hat wohl er hat mir wohl mal irgendwie im stream einer geschickt oder so
tickenleiser müssen wir noch machen so irgendwie
ich glaube so ist ganz gut ja leute über skate
aber was trinken
ich habe seit 20 jahren den gleichen wassersprung klar und das ding von
zimmern auch das war mal was was sich gelohnt hat das war auch nicht teuer
damals das zeug und ich habe auch immer noch die uhr allen flaschen auf der
Flasche hier steht, glaube ich, die ist nur bis
2005 oder so verwenden.
Steht hier irgendwo drauf.
Nicht mehr verwenden. Na, ich sehe es gar nicht mehr.
Aber irgendwas in der Richtung
steht hier irgendwo drauf.
Nicht nach... Hier 2006
steht hier drauf, genau.
Nicht nach Oktober 2006 verwenden.
Tja.
20 Jahre
später geht immer noch.
Ist hier aus
Plastik.
Ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall ist die aus Plastik.
Ich weiß, die neuen, die haben
auch die Möglichkeit, Glasflaschen
zu verwenden. Aber
ganz ehrlich, das tut ganz gut.
So, Leute.
Dann müssen wir jetzt erst einmal
Deine Meinung zu
Cache.ios.
Sag ich dir gleich.
Wir starten erstmal CacheOS, dass wir über CacheOS reden können.
Die können bersten und das Plastik fängt sich an zu zersetzen.
Ja.
Genau nach 20 Jahren hat sich schon alles zersetzt
Ja
Ja, vielleicht
Ihr habt gar nicht so unrecht
Vielleicht soll ich mal wirklich
Neue Flasche oder neue Flaschen
Kaufen
Auf starte das verdammte Spiel.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
So, gucken wir mal, ob er das jetzt irgendwann nochmal hinkriegt mit starten.
Jawoll, exzellent.
Moment, was ist hier los?
Warum?
Achso, weil der mal wieder die Logitech-Software nicht gestartet hat, oder?
Da weiß der teilweise nicht bei dem Krempel.
What the fuck?
Warum geht meine Logitech-Geschichte nicht?
Was ist da los?
Ja, ja.
Das sollte doch eigentlich...
Ja.
Geht doch.
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Also, dann kann ich mich dazu auslassen.
Das ist nämlich eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich verwende nämlich CacheOS jetzt selbst schon seit ein paar Monaten.
Mit KDE.
Das heißt, was ich sage, erstreckt sich nur auf CacheOS mit KDE.
Und dazu kann ich sagen, ich finde es nice.
Also ich kann das empfehlen.
Es ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt das mit Abstand beste System für Linux-Einsteiger
Das ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt
Also wenn man sich ein bisschen an Linux rantasten will, man darf nicht vergessen, CacheOS ist immer noch ein Arsch Linux unter der Haube
Man muss aber relativ wenig wissen
Es gibt aber trotzdem Sachen, die einfacher sind
Warum es CacheOS heißt, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum es CacheOS heißt
vielleicht wegen irgendwelchen
Kernels, Scheduler, Dingern oder so
keine Ahnung, ob es CacheOS heißt
was mir ganz gut gefällt bei CacheOS
ist diese Geschichte hier, also unter anderem
ja, wenn du jetzt
irgendwas installierst, sagt mal
irgendwas, was kann ich denn, SL
irgendwas, hier guck mal
wenn ich jetzt was installiere, dann
ich installiere jetzt mal was
dann macht der automatisch
zumindest wenn man BTFS
verwendet, was standardmäßig glaube ich sogar
mittlerweile ausgewählt ist, dann macht
er automatisch einen Snapshot.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt
mein System zerschieße,
und so, dass es nicht mehr bootet,
ne, Cache ist nicht immutable,
wenn ich mir jetzt mein System zerschieße, so, dass es
nicht mehr bootet, habe ich im
Bootmenü, also, ne, Bootmenü
trifft sich wirklich im Bootmanager,
also im Crab oder in
Limein oder wie das andere Ding
heißt, habe ich Auswahl
der letzten Snapshots und kann
quasi auf den Stand zurück. Bootloader.
Ja, Bootloader.
Kann auf den Stand zurück, bevor ich es mir
zerschossen habe. Das ist richtig nice.
Ich finde das auch gut. Das ist nicht kompliziert.
Das kriegt man bei anderen Betriebssystemen auch.
Ein paar Packages nachher zählt. Aber ich finde es richtig gut,
dass das standardmäßig damit kommt.
Das ist nämlich out of the box was,
wo man sich denkt, ah, richte ich
das jetzt ein? Ach, das brauchen wir doch eigentlich
gar nicht. Und dann macht man es nicht.
Die Slapshots sind nur
mit BTFS. Ich bin mir
nicht sicher. Vielleicht auch mit
ZFS, aber ich glaube nicht
mit ZFS, weil Krupp und so
haben keinen Support für
ZFS-Snapshots. Also
wahrscheinlich nur mit BTFS, denke
ich mal. Ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
bei den meisten Kisten spricht ja auch nichts wirklich dagegen,
BTFS zu verwenden.
Ist eigentlich bei BTFS
mittlerweile
Raid 5 und 6 stable?
Oder gibt es immer noch eine Warnung?
Also lass mal kurz gucken.
WTFS Raid 6.
Ist es sicher zu verwenden?
Stand September 2005 wird von der Verwendung von WTFS mit Raid 5 noch abgerannt.
Ja, seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Uqueenforum.de
Ja, also
Die sagen selbst,
man soll es nicht verwenden. Ich könnte mir
durchaus vorstellen, dass das
wahrscheinlich bei 99,99%
der Leute keinerlei Probleme macht.
The name
CashUS originated
from the Cashi scale.
Das ist so, dachte ich mir auch, dass du was damit zu tun hast.
Which was the old name of the Kack... was? Kackule?
Der Kackule. Kackule-Scheduler.
Oder ist es Französisch? Heißt Kekulé oder so.
Kekulé. Keine Ahnung, ich kann kein Französisch.
Hatte dich letzten Stream wegen Junior-Linux-Vorstellungsgespräch gefragt.
Hab mich mit Z-Servers vorbereitet.
Lief perfekt.
Exzellent.
Warst du das?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Nee, oder?
Meinte, die zu dir gesagt haben, du sollst per SSH dich irgendwo einloggen und was zeigen?
Doch, oder?
Erzähl mal.
Was wollten die so wissen von dir?
Ist ja auf Lauf...
Ist, denke ich, auch für den Chat ganz interessant.
Die sind ja vielleicht auch mal in der...
Lage, dass dann...
Irgendwann oder in der Situation, das machen zu müssen.
Erzähl uns doch mal, was die genau von dir vorgeführt haben wollten.
Also wie gesagt, CacheOS kann ich empfehlen.
Auch, wie gesagt, es ist nicht das allerbeste System für Einsteiger.
So nach dem Motto, wer in der Anlage noch gar nichts, null Linux-Berührungspunkte hat, geht das?
Ja, es ist vielleicht nicht das Beste dafür.
Kann man aber ohne Probleme machen.
Ich finde das gut.
Ich habe das jetzt seit ein paar Monaten hier schon mit KDE auf so einem Mini-PC.
Das ist ein Beelink SR7.
Oder Beelink SR7.
Oder wie heißt das jetzt?
Ja, so ein Teil, so ein kleiner Mini-PC.
Das ist auch, muss ich auch sagen, es ist jetzt gar nicht so extrem RAM-hungrig.
Ihr seht es ja hier.
Das Ding hat tatsächlich nur 8 GB RAM.
Ich bin auch zu geizig, gerade mir mehr zu kaufen.
8g aber dafür hat es halt ordentlich wenn ich tippen könnte 8 core ryzen cpu
und amd grafikkarte also eigentlich für linux perfekt also ich könnte es also
ich würde es wieder installieren auf der kiste
Man spricht es ja eigentlich auch gar nicht
BTRFS aus, wobei ich das
persönlich die beste Aussprache finde.
Ich glaube es heißt entweder
ButterFS oder BetterFS.
Aber
ganz ehrlich, ich sage immer BTRFS.
Aber Ext4, nicht
Ext.
Okay, also erstmal haben sie dich Basic-Sachen gefragt.
Schau dich mal im System um, finde mal raus, was da so drauf ist.
Ja, okay.
Dann die Frage, wenn ich dir den Server für 50 Euro im Monat vermieten würde, wäre das fair?
Wahrscheinlich können sie mit hetzener Preis nicht mithalten.
Ähm, ja gut, das sind ja durchaus angemessene Fragen für eine Einstiegsstelle,
wo man sieht, okay, die Leute haben ein bisschen Ahnung von Linux, ja,
guckst du mal, was unter etc. so Zeug für Config-Dateien liegen,
guckst du mal, was für Packages installiert sind, guckst du erstmal überhaupt nach,
was das für ein System so ist, ja, kannst du dir etc. Debian-Version, Red Hat-Version,
einmal linux version was auch immer die angucken oder lsb release was es dann auch gibt gibt es
ja zig zu zig so dateien ja aber das war schön ja und war das jetzt erste bewerbungsrunde oder haben
die schon gesagt die neben dich wie ist das dann am ende wie war das dann business komponenten
Was, Keck-Business?
Also ein bisschen Business hat ja mittlerweile jede Stelle.
Okay, außer vielleicht IBM Mainframe Admins oder sowas.
Die wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das B3F File System.
manchmal noch ButterFS.
Sag ich doch.
Das gibt es erst seit 2016?
Das gibt es erst 10 Jahre?
Mir kommt das länger vor. Achso, Moment.
Seit 2007.
Okay.
Moment. Plattformenübergreifend
für Windows. Moment.
Moment. Moment.
Es gibt BTFS für
Windows?
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Hä.
Ja, was es nicht alles gibt, das wusste ich nicht, dass es BTFS für Windows gibt.
Naja, ein bisschen mit Business, also komm doch mal an, was du meinst mit Business,
aber so ein bisschen mit Business hast du ja auch schon zu tun,
weil die Leute wollen ja von dir irgendwelche Features haben, aufgrund von,
weil irgendwelche Anwender gesagt haben, sie hätten das gerne, weil irgendjemand von euren Businessleuten meint, das ist sinnvoll.
Ja, also ein bisschen Überschneidung hat das immer.
Ich habe auch so gut wie nichts mit Business zu tun, ja.
Das Einzige, was ich mit Cake Business zu tun habe, ist, wenn mal wieder irgendeiner sagt,
Können wir die 4Ms nicht ein bisschen kleiner
Saisen, dass sie nicht so teuer sind
Oder sowas
Das gibt es auch für Windows
Das kann durchaus sein, dass wir das schon hatten
Weiß ich jetzt nicht
Aber mir ist es neu
Tatsächlich
Ja KDE
Gab es glaube ich auch mal für Windows
Ich glaube mittlerweile
Mittlerweile wird das, glaube ich, nicht mehr unterstützt.
Was richtig cool war, ist aber schon uralt.
Wie hieß das denn?
Das war lange vor WSL.
Kolinux?
Hieß das vielleicht so?
Ja.
Das ist uralt.
Guck mal, das ist von 2004.
Das ist nichts, was man jetzt irgendwie noch verwenden sollte.
aber
das war quasi
WSL, bevor es
WSL offiziell von Microsoft gab
die haben quasi den Linux Kernel
auf Windows laufen lassen
it's a port of the Linux Kernel
ja
da denke ich auch nicht dran
dass LinkedIn zu Microsoft gehört
das ist eigentlich richtig cool, du konntest damals
Ubuntu, boah keine Ahnung
8.10 oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder Knobbix oder sonst was.
Konntest du damals
schon mit GUI, wohlgemerkt.
Mit GUI konntest du
unter Windows laufen lassen. Guck hier,
das ist ein Knobbix von damals.
Dass da Zirkwind steht, dürft ihr euch nicht
beeindrucken lassen. Das ist damals nur für den
X-Server gewesen.
Das war WSL, bevor es WSL
von Microsoft gab.
guck mal linux kernel 2.6 ist halt schon ein bisschen älter ja
das sind keine container ich habe das habe ich mich auch schon immer gefragt und ich
habe keine antwort drauf wie man das genau macht also sie haben den linux kernel wohl
irgendwie kompiliert für windows ich check's auch nicht genau weil wenn du
zwei körner nebeneinander laufen hast die kommen sich doch die kommen sich
doch auch mit mit speicherverwaltung und so voll in die quere sagt eine anwendung
ich hätte gerne dann macht es irgendwie virtual memory und und und im zweifel
verlangt ist oder auf dem gleichen wahrscheinlich also meine vermutung ist
dass sie den Linux-Kernel quasi als User-Programm oder so laufen lassen oder als Windows-Kernel-Modul oder irgendwie sowas
und die echten Hardware-Zugriffe irgendwie abstrahieren und umbiegen auf Windows-Kernel-Sachen.
Ich habe aber echt keinen blassen Schimmer, wie die das genau gemacht haben.
Keine Ahnung, das habe ich mich schon immer gefragt
Aber eigentlich richtig cool damals gewesen
Ich habe das auch tatsächlich mal eine Weile damals auf meinem Arbeitslaptop
2008 oder so verwendet
Eine richtig coole Sache
Leider wurde das nie wirklich groß angenommen
und
nie weiterentwickelt.
Aber an sich war das, wie gesagt,
das war WSL, WSL 1 wohl
gemerkt. WSL 1,
weil WSL 2 ist ja eigentlich auch nur eine
VM unter der Haube. Das ist quasi
WSL 1
lange, lange
15 Jahre bevor es WSL
gab. Also das war ein richtig cooles
Projekt damals.
Ja.
Ja, so spannend ist das nicht.
Im Endeffekt sieht es halt aus wie WSL mit einem X-Server dann.
Dann wird Miniri weiter.
Ich weiß nicht, mir geht es heute nicht so gut.
Deswegen habe ich den Stream angeschmissen, um mich ein bisschen abzulenken.
Deswegen ist der Titel des Streams
tatsächlich auch nur zur Hälfte
Kappa.
Weil ich, weil, zu mir hat
man, als ich,
als ich noch, äh,
hier Therapie gemacht hab, vor nem
Jahr, hat man meinen,
äh, Psychologe
damals gesagt,
ähm, also
dem hab ich ja mal irgendwann erzählt, dass ich
Livestream mache, und er hat gesagt,
weißt was, also,
Hat er nicht so gesagt, aber sinngemäß hat er gesagt, weiß was.
Wenn ihr dir mal so viele Gedanken macht,
die es nicht so gut geht, macht doch einfach Stream an.
Da habe ich mir gedacht,
exzellente Idee.
Dann mache ich das doch.
LX Core Sys ist der
Kernel Driver des WSL 1.
Aha.
Okay, das scheint echt komplizierte Sache zu sein.
Okay, das...
Beim Umschauen im System habe ich Systemctl gesehen, ja.
Dass da ein Apache-Server drauf ist, der beim Starten fällt.
Das sollte ich mir angucken.
Dann habe ich die Logs geguckt, gesehen, woran es liegt und die Zeile geändert.
Okay, dann haben die das halt extra so manipuliert, um zu wissen, ob man so die Basics kann.
übrigens was auch immer praktisch ist um zu gucken was drauf ist system ctl system ctl list
und da gibt es hier so ein paar sachen da macht man meistens list list units oder list unit files
list units da sieht man was ist hier für startscripts skriptors quasi unit files drauf gibt
danach wurde gesagt dass ich das ganze system updaten soll man ab denn ist dns
resolving gefehlt gefällt weil er in resulten lokal ausstand als letztes sollte ich sehr
mod die exekute rechte wegnehmen und das fixen hat versuch kaltes zu deinstallieren ging nicht
Aber reinstall ging, hat's gefixt. Aha.
War geil.
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
Da siehst du, die haben sich tatsächlich mal was
beigedacht. Und wollen
die dich jetzt haben?
Oder weiß man noch nicht?
Hast du noch Kontakte? Selten.
Also zum Kabum schon ewig
nichts mehr.
Zum Fabian
ab und zu mal über
Discord, aber auch selten.
gibt auch aktuell nichts was wir zusammen spielen können
ist ja was ich letztens gesehen habe dass man also hier
Keck JavaScript.
Ähm, das
Bann
jetzt rewritet
zu Rust. Habt ihr das auch gelesen?
Ne, mit beiden keinen Kontakt.
Ähm,
also was der Danny macht, hab ich keine Ahnung.
Schnee, wie ich nichts gehört.
Ähm, so.
Ja, und, ähm,
Ban wurde jetzt irgendwie
zu, von
Sig zu Rust
oder soll von
geportet werden?
So genau
check ich's ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Warum?
Ähm, zumindest
ist, also
meine persönliche Vermutung ist,
ja, dass
Ach, ist das jetzt schon hier die
Rust-Geschichte?
Ja, boring SSL,
das klingt sehr nach Rust.
Also, meine Vermutung ist,
ja,
die porten das zu Rust,
damit sie sagen
können, guckt mal her,
wie geil Cloud Code ist,
weil BAN gehört ja in Tropic.
das sind die cloud code leute hinter bahn mittlerweile ich habe den eindruck
dass es eigentlich in hauptmann wieder so ein prestige projekt für ein topik
dass sie sagen können guck mal wir haben eine komplette java script runtime
wobei das stimmt ja gar nicht so wirklich das java script runtime ist ja
die von safari bei bahn wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe alle andere
benutzen v8 das ist die java script runtime von chrome oder von chrome kann
man ja gar nicht mal sagen link wie heißt das jetzt genau ach keiner
chrome weiß jeder was gemeint ist die javascript runtime von chrome
oder javascript engine von chrome oder jemand nennen mag und bahn benutzt
javascript engine von safari ehrlich gesagt absolut kein schimmer was sie
dazu geritten hat irgendwas von safari freiwillig zu verwenden
Safari ist ja im Prinzip der neue Internet Explorer.
Also wenn es ein cooles neues Feature gibt und Chrome und Firefox können das Feature,
kannst du es erstmal die nächsten 5 Jahre nicht benutzen, bis Safari es irgendwann mal auf die Reihe gekriegt hat.
Safari ist da teilweise richtig outdated, overrated, jebaited.
naja
und ich hab die
ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl
ich hab keine Ahnung
warum sie es wirklich porten
jeder iOS Browser muss
Safari benutzen, ja ja, ich weiß
aber trotzdem sagt Safari
es gibt ja
diese Seite hier, can I use
so, schauen wir mal was
ähm
Okay, guck mal mal was
Date, wie heißt denn diese neue
Date, ähm
Äh
New TS Date Time
Wie heißt dieser Kram
Ja, da gibt es doch eine neue
Temporal, der Chat weiß
Wieder Bescheid, ey
So, guck mal mal
Haha, wer hätte gedacht
Jeder kann es, wer kann es nicht
Safari kann es nicht.
Kein Wunder, Alter.
Das ist immer der gleiche Kack.
Die können das...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Im Safari Technology Preview kann man jetzt eine Runtime Flag setzen.
Use Temporal.
Dann geht das auch.
Guck mal, wie lang Chrome und...
Alter.
Ah, die Seite.
Wie lang Chrome und Firefox diesen Mist schon haben.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht...
Das ist auch relativ neu, muss man dazu sagen.
Aber das ist immerhin schon über ein Jahr alt.
Spielst du Battlefield 6?
Nee.
Ich habe letztens gesehen, es gibt wohl eine Map in Deutschland jetzt bei Battlefield 6.
Tja.
Ja, wie auch immer die Safari updaten, aber die sind bekannt dafür,
richtig weit hinten dran zu sein.
Bei vielen Features.
Wo die auch richtig lange gebraucht haben,
ist, weiß gar nicht, ob man das damit
findet,
bei dem, was du für
eine Progressive Web Application
PWA brauchst,
das hat ewig gebraucht.
Ich weiß es leider nicht genau, wie die
ganzen, guck mal hier, das ist auch für Safari,
weil das haben die als Gefahr für ihren App Store
gesehen und
dann haben die sich gedacht, nö, haben wir keinen Bock dran.
ja also safari ist ich deswegen sage ich immer safari ist der der neue internet
explorer die sind teilweise jahre hinten dran bei
dem was die was sie für features haben das ist das teilweise echt kannst du
kannst du kannst ja eigentlich nahezu sicher sein wenn es irgendwas neues
cooles gibt wie zum beispiel die neue daytime api und firefox und chrome
unterstützen endlich kann sagen okay eigentlich so richtig verwenden kann man
noch nicht, weil Safari benutzt das halt.
Oder Safari hat es immer noch nicht drin.
Ja.
Oh, Leute. Ich muss mal ganz kurz.
Ich muss mal dringend kurz pinkeln. Ich bin
gleich wieder am Start.
Mach ich mal eine Runde.
Oh, ich hab Bauchweh. WTF? Was ist denn jetzt
los? Ich hab
eine Riesenportion Spargel.
Grüne Spargel.
Mit Kartoffel gegessen. Also
jetzt nix.
Oh. WTF?
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Also im Plan steht, dass ich gerade übelst Bauchweh habe.
So von jetzt auf gleich.
Okay, es kann durchaus sein, dass ich nicht nur pinkeln muss, sondern gleich mal afklo.
Ja, aber jetzt muss ich mal, Leute, ich muss mal kurz pinkeln.
Ich gucke mal, vielleicht kann ich das andere auch gleich mit erledigen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich habe doch hier sogar so ein afklo.
Okay, Leute, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, wieder am Start.
Also.
Da bin ich wieder.
Wie gesagt,
kann sein, dass ich gleich nochmal muss.
Gucken wir, wie das mit dem Bauchweh
sich entwickelt. Wo sind wir denn gerade
stehen geblieben? Achso, ich hab Safari geflamed,
dass Safari der neue Internet Explorer
ist. Geht's besser? Ich war nur
pinkeln. Guck mal, vielleicht legt sich
das mit Bauchschmerzen ja wieder.
Genau, ich habe Safari geflamed, dass Safari der neue Internet Explorer ist.
Und wie sind wir da hingekommen?
Genau, von BAN, weil BAN ja Safari, glaube ich, als JavaScript-Engine verwendet.
Genau, und jetzt haben sie BAN irgendwie zu Rust portiert.
Wahrscheinlich ist da für Cloud Code drei Wochen gelaufen oder so.
Kann man vor allem in Workstation auch ohne Account downloaden?
also offiziell von vmware nicht aber vielleicht findest du ja irgendwo bei heise oder chip oder
sonst wo den download aber du kannst ja auch einfach einen account mit fake e mail adresse
machen hier ist irgendwie keine ahnung 10 minute mail oder sowas suchst dir irgendeine
random Adresse raus und
registrierst dich bei
VMware.
Ja.
Zumindest wofür
der BunRust
Port schon geflamed
wurde, also das hier, ne, das ist
alles Cloud Code generated,
wofür das schon
geflamed wurde,
ist, dass die
so oft
unsafe verwenden.
Was ist denn das? Kann man sich trauen, das
aufzumachen?
The best disposable mail
service. Aha.
Was es nicht alles gibt, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Und BUN wurde schon öfters, guck mal hier, die haben so viel unsaved, WTF pass double.
Das heißt halt einfach, Cloud Code hat SIG zu Rust mit unsaved drin geportet.
Da wurde, hier, BUN, unsaved Rust, da wurde BUN schon wieder heftig geflamed, auch bei Hacker News und allem.
Ich glaube, Theo hat auch ein Video zu, wo er die geflamed hat.
Und ich persönlich verstehe den Port von BAN zu Rust nicht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es halt so ein Marketing-Ding von Anthropic wieder ist.
Wie gesagt, die Cloud-Code-Leute, denen gehört ja BAN mittlerweile.
Was ich in der Tat ganz interessant finde, was ich schon immer mal ausprobieren wollte,
wo ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob wir das nicht sogar schon mal ausprobiert haben,
Ne anscheinend nicht
Was ich mal schon immer ausprobieren wollte ist
Bun hat
Das könnten wir theoretisch jetzt sogar mal
Schnell ausprobieren
Bun hat ja die Möglichkeit
Dass man Standalone
Executables baut aus
Javascript
Anwendungen hier
Bun self
Selfcontained Executable
So, kann man bauen und ihr LibC, da kann man Target auswählen.
So und was mich jetzt mal interessieren würde ist, wenn ich hier mit One Linux x64 Musel das Ganze kompiliere, ob es dann wirklich ein richtig echtes Standalone Binary ist, so ein bisschen wie Go.
oder ob das nach wie vor abhängig ist
zur jeweiligen libc-Implementierung
und dementsprechend dann nur
auf neueren Linux-Systemen läuft,
wenn man es auf neueren Linux-Systemen kompiliert hat.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ich meine, das dauert ja nicht lang.
Wir installieren einfach mal ban.
Boden.
So.
Dann machen wir ein Hello World
JavaScript.
Da gucken wir mal.
Hier. CD. Temp.
Wie, ich habe noch keinen...
Temp.
Äh, mkdir, ban, lel.
Äh, vim, main.js, console.
Was, log ist es, ne?
Cute, chat, ajaja.
So.
Beste.
Ban, kann man jetzt die Datei einfach so ausführen?
Okay, funzt.
So, wie geht das jetzt denn?
Nimmst du nicht die dev-Container dafür?
also für ein einzelnes javascript fall was ich packe nicht normalerweise
nämlich der container dafür der fronter sind übrigens immer noch kaputt auf der
echten hardware linux kiste keine ahnung warum aber für diese also für ein für
die einzel javascript datei die ich damit jetzt bandel dann brauche ich das
nicht aber ansonsten nämlich immer der container was man übrigens auch gesehen
hat dass das sehr sinnvoll ist weil
Ja, keine Ahnung, die erste
Seite, die hier was gefunden hat.
Weil
Mini-Schei-Hulut
ist wieder am Start.
Supply Chain Angriff
affecting
CanStack.
Es gab wieder
NPM Supply Chain Angriffe.
Das ist aber ja mittlerweile
eigentlich gar keine News mehr wert.
Weil das eh jede Woche
mindestens einmal vorkommt.
Keck.js, ja.
To support CPUs from before 2000...
Okay.
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen...
Ah, minus Baseline ist für alte CPUs.
Verstehe.
Okay, dann probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Wir kompilieren das mit BAN und dann gucken wir mal, wie sehr rückwärtskompatibel das Ganze ist.
Main.
Also wir kompilieren es für Linux x64.
so also auf dem gleichen system sollte das ja funktionieren okay passt wir können mal kurz
gucken was das sagt ob das static oder beine ob das static das ist okay das ist der name
linkt das wird schon mal probleme geben das auszuführen auf ein bisschen älteren systemen
probieren das noch mal aus docker ron alma linux näher kommen wir nehmen mal irgendwas
Debian auf Trixi.
Trixi könnte es tatsächlich laufen.
Debian Trixi.
Ach ne, wir müssen das ja
mounten. Minus V.
Kann man mittlerweile sowas eigentlich machen?
In Docker? Nach App?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Müssen wir machen.
Home.
TMP.
Bunlel.
pwd ja ach das muss der form er sagen was hat er für schmerzen
wo ist wo ist das was für ein problem
leben
ich jetzt so dumm doch zu starten gerade
will ich es muss auch vor dem ian tricks ii okay
Wie gesagt, Demian Trixi.
Alter!
Sag mal!
Donker Run!
Also so fängt es ja prinzipiell an.
Das muss doch so funktionieren.
Was hat er denn?
Invalid Spec.
App.
Empty Section.
Empty Section?
Aber das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Hä?
Es ist Dollar, PWD.
Aber, okay.
Jetzt.
Okay, das war echt eine schwere Geburt.
So, gehen wir mal hier nach Slash App.
So, geht nicht.
Weil Lip IQ ist nicht drauf.
Ach, das braucht der auch.
Okay.
Ähm, kann man das irgendwie static
Kompilieren, wann?
Nee
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt das nächste
Probieren wir mal
Also das funktioniert schon nochmal nett
Wie man sieht, das ist
Dann muss man das wieder auf dem richtig alten
Linux kompilieren, wenn man will, dass das funktioniert
Ähm, sie haben sogar LibEco
Als Anforderung, also so
Wirklich schön self-contained
Ist die Anwendung ja nett
muss man sagen.
So, dann sagen wir
BAN.
Moment hier. BAN.
BAN compile. Ne, BAN
build compile target.
Was war das andere? Baseline.
Base,
wenn man es richtig schreiben will.
Baseline.
Okay.
Ist von
97. File.
My App.
Ist immer noch dynamically linked.
Aber, guck mal, tatsächlich
Für ein älteres Linux jetzt auch
App
My App, das funktioniert schon
Immer
Das ist gut zu wissen
Also wenn man Linux
x64 Baseline nimmt
Dann ist das
Schon mal auch laufweg auf
Älteren Linux System
Debian ist ja standardmäßig älter
Wir machen jetzt nochmal ein richtig altes Linux.
Was ist Trixi 12, gell?
Ne, 13. Trixi ist 13.
Trixi ist 13.
Genau.
Dann mal Bookworm war davor.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal Debian 10.
Das war Wheezy oder irgendwie sowas.
Und das ist noch älter.
Geht immer noch.
Sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut.
Na gut, Kernel.
Ja.
Sehr gut. Also,
die, äh, diese Kombination hier
mit Baseline führt echt
dazu, dass die Dinger ziemlich gut
abwärtskompatibel sind. Okay,
machen wir mal was ganz
altes. Äh, Debian
Version. Warte mal, lass mal gucken.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal einen Debian.
Jesse.
Jessie nehmen wir mal.
Das ist richtig alt.
Oder alternativ können wir auch
Edge nehmen.
Edge war in meiner Ausbildung
voll angesagt noch.
Wir nehmen mal Jessie.
Übrigens, wer sich fragt, wo die Namen herkommen,
das sind alles Charaktere aus
Toy Story.
Jessie ist der Cowboy.
Pixie ist
der Dinosaurier.
Buster ist, glaube ich, der Hund.
Gut, Woody ist der Cowboy
Äh, Jessie ist die Cowboy-In
Woody ist der Cowboy
Sarge ist glaube ich der
Der Spielzeugsoldat
Ja
Zed ist das böse Kind, genau, ja
Guck mal, die Anwendungen laufen rückwirkend
rückwirkend. Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen,
ich laufe ja immer noch
immer noch mit dem aktuellen Körnel, ne?
Also ob das wirklich
so lange rück... Müsste man
in der VM oder so mal testen.
Aber es sieht zumindest danach aus,
als ist, wenn man BAN
mit Baseline kompiliert,
das eigentlich
schon mal ganz gut, muss man sagen.
So, wie kann man das Ganze jetzt mit...
Ah.
Jetzt haben wir die...
Ne, jetzt haben wir keine G-Lib C, sondern die Musel-Variante.
Ist die Static?
Die ist nicht Static.
Die ist auch dynamisch dagegen gelinkt.
Das ist dann was für...
Alpine Linux und sowas.
Weil das sollte jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren.
Genau.
Ne, die Fehlermeldung ist ein bisschen dumm.
Ja, also...
Die App ist schon da.
Die Fehlermeldung ist ein bisschen bescheuert.
Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht, weil das kein Musel installiert hat, sondern nur GLibc.
Dann probieren wir doch mal was anderes.
Das finde ich immer ein bisschen... Also, ganz ehrlich, es wäre viel nicer, wenn die die Möglichkeit anbieten, dass man, wenn man schon gegen Musel linkt, das statisch linken könnte, weil außer Alpine benutzt keine Linux-Distribution Musel.
Musel ist so eine Mini-C-Library-Implementierung, die angeblich viel, frag mich nicht, portabler ist oder so.
Gibt es denn die Möglichkeit, wann, wie ist das Ding, compile, wann compile static? Geht das vielleicht auch?
Implement static linking.
Okay, das gibt es anscheinend noch nicht.
Was?
Moment, ich soll jetzt, damit ich ein statisches Binary erzeugen kann,
soll ich BUN selbst erst statisch kompilieren, oder was?
Ja, man könnte es ja auch übertreiben.
Ich habe entschieden, Bun in einer statischen Art zu recompilen.
aber es ist nicht auf dem gleichen Niveau wie beispielsweise Go von der Portability her.
Portabilität oder wie soll ich sagen?
Weil ein Go-Binary, also ohne C-Go, ist komplett statisch.
Das kannst du auf Linux Sidekernel 2632 draufschieben und es läuft.
egal ob gelb c musel oder julip c oder was ist da nicht alles gibt vollkommen egal es geht und
deswegen ist golf für portable binaries einfach das beste was es gibt deswegen ist das meiner
meinung nach auch so beliebt über die tools weil ein tool mit go also jetzt wie gesagt ohne dass
du externe abhängigkeiten zu irgendwelchen c geschichten hast oder so ist super easy zu
deployen oder auch zu containerisieren.
Das muss einfach
reinkopiert werden, das läuft.
Du kannst bei Go
sogar das Docker-Scratch-Image
verwenden, wo nichts drin ist, quasi,
außer das Binary. Das geht.
Also Go ist da
schon wirklich sehr premium.
So, wir probieren jetzt nochmal was aus.
Ich habe jetzt hier die
GLibc-Variante und wenn ich die jetzt mal
starte in einem
Alpine-Linux,
Alpine Latest,
dann sollte das ja eigentlich nicht funktionieren.
Achso, bin
SH.
Ja. App.
My App. Bam. Geht nicht.
Okay.
Aber das ist trotzdem ganz gut.
Also,
also wenn ich jetzt
eine Anwendung in JavaScript machen
müsste, sagen wir auch irgendein CLI-Tool,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen müsste ich das in JavaScript machen,
weil spezielle Libraries
nur für JavaScript gibt und es damit so viel
einfacher ist, dass sich das drumherum lohnt,
das dann nicht in Go zu machen
oder in einer anderen Sprache.
JavaScript.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich wirklich Bun benutzen,
um da meinen
Binary draus zu erzeugen.
Also wenn ich was suche, was ich verteilen will,
weil das ist, zumindest hier mit
Baseline, ist das nahezu
auf allen Linux-Distributionen der letzten
15 Jahre oder so lauffähig.
Oder in den letzten 10 Jahren mindestens lauffähig.
Jessie ist von 2015 gewesen.
Lauffähig.
Die GLIPC-based sind. Was alle sind.
Oder sagen wir mal zu 99%
Linux-Distributionen sind.
Die einzige größere, die mir einfällt,
die nicht GLIPC-based ist,
das ist Alpine.
Und Alpine hat auch noch ein paar andere Probleme.
Ich bin überhaupt kein Alpine-Linux-Fan mehr.
Ich habe das früher gerne benutzt für Container.
Mittlerweile benutze ich entweder einfach stinknormales minimales Debian, weil die bisschen größere Imagegröße jetzt eigentlich gar keinen großen Unterschied macht.
Das ist nicht das, was teuer ist.
Oder aber wenn es eine Go-Anwendung ist oder irgendwas, was sich statisch kompilieren lässt, dann entweder Distroless Images oder Scratch Image.
Rust
Ich glaube, mein Bun
ist noch die Sick-Variante, oder?
Gehe ich mal stark von aus
Warte mal
Release, ja, guck mal
Meins ist noch die Sick-Variante
Alpine hat immer mal wieder Probleme
mit DNS-Auflösung und sowas
wegen Lip Musel.
Ja, ist mega. Rust allerdings zum Laufen
zu bringen, braucht haufenweise C-Abhängigkeit.
Du kannst doch mittlerweile
Rust
Static als
Rust Static Binary
kompilieren. Das war doch gar nicht
so kompliziert.
Das haben wir doch sogar mal im Stream gemacht.
Das war doch an sich gar nicht so schwierig.
Du musstest im Endeffekt
nur sagen, du willst static Musel target
und dann ging das.
Gut, je nachdem
was für Abhängigkeiten du natürlich hast,
dann wird es vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber an sich war Rust relativ
einfach komplett statisch zu kompilieren.
Du benutzt
Alma Linux minimal. Ey, Alma Linux,
ich wusste, dass es das gibt,
ja, genauso wie Rockli Linux,
so quasi als
kostenlose Red Hat Varianten.
Aber
die haben echt Pluspunkte gesammelt
letzte Woche bei mir. So im Kopf.
Weil, sie erinnert euch ja
bestimmt noch an
Dirty Frack.
So. Und da hat
Alma Linux vor Red Hat,
lange vor Red Hat,
nee, nee, ich mein Dirty Frack.
Copy Fail war vor zwei Wochen.
Letzte Woche war Dirty Frack.
Mittlerweile ist es ja so,
dass es jede Woche irgendwas gibt, Alter.
Und
Alma Linux hatte schon am 7.
Mai
ein Testing-Patch
für Dirty Frag.
Red Hat hatte
bis
gestern
Mittag
nur Packages
für Red Hat 10, glaube ich.
Lass doch mal gucken.
gucken wir mal was red hat mittlerweile hat das meine ich nicht moment
important ja mach witz red hat
Also du kannst Rust gegen Musel kompilieren und dann ist das komplett statisch.
Und du brauchst dann eigentlich keine Abhängigkeiten.
Wo du Abhängigkeiten brauchst ist, wenn deine Rust-Dependencies selber irgendwelche Dependencies haben.
Dann gibt es Probleme.
Zum Beispiel gab es längere Zeit mal Probleme mit OpenSSL zum Beispiel.
Aber ich kann dir das zeigen.
Das ist eigentlich relativ easy.
Da muss ich aber meine alte VM neu starten.
Weil ich glaube, ich habe hier keinen Rust drauf.
Und ich weiß gerade aus dem Kopf auch gar nicht mehr, wie man es richtig einrichtet.
So, ähm, lassen wir mal hier kurz was gucken.
Red Hat sagt genau, fixed, okay, mittlerweile, guckt mal hier.
Chatgear, guckt mal hier.
Übrigens, dann habe ich Mist erzählt.
Ich dachte, bis gestern Mittag gab es noch nichts.
Ach doch, doch, doch, okay.
11.
Dann habe ich gestern Morgen geguckt.
11. kam das raus und gestern
kam dann 8 und 9.
Wo ist Red Hat 9?
Red Hat 9?
Äh, hallo?
Achso, da unten geht die Seite noch weiter.
Red Hat 9. Okay.
Also da muss ich sagen, guckt mal hier.
Da hat Alma Linux bei mir echt
Pluspunkte gesammelt.
einmal linux ist ja quasi ein ich weiß gar nicht was die offiziell zu sich sagen das ist quasi ein red hat nachbau halt nur genau
einmal linux us binary kompatibel wird enterprise das ist quasi nennt nen red hat ohne red hat
die anderen logos und so zeug ausgetauscht also die neben quasi red hat sources und bauen eigenes betriebssystem
draus du hast quasi dann ein kostenloses red hat so und da muss man gucken
Gucken, bei Red Hat bezahlst du ordentlich Asche für.
Und Alma Linux hatte am 7.
Guck mal hier, am 7. hatten die schon Testing-Patches und später dann auch,
guck mal, am 8.5., mittags am 8.5. hatten die Kernel-Patches draußen für Dirty Frag.
Und Red Hat hatte das irgendwann gestern.
Also die waren vier Tage.
Die waren quasi als kostenloses Red Hat vier Tage schneller als bezahltes Red Hat für ihre Patches.
Das ist schon nice, oder?
Mit Rocky Linux habe ich...
Ehrlich gesagt, müssen wir mal gucken.
Haben die überhaupt sowas?
Haben die irgendwie sowas, wo man da nachgucken kann?
Okay, da bin ich zu dumm, das für Rocky Linux zu finden.
Ja.
Aber das ist schon nice.
Der Rata Rocky Linux.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Dirty.
Das ist es nicht.
Okay, dann weiß ich nicht, wie ich das hier finden soll.
Was bei mir dazu geführt hätte, wenn ich jetzt mich entscheiden müsste,
Ich will ein freies, kostenloses Red Hat haben.
Nämlich Rocky Linux oder Alma Linux.
Hätte ich jetzt gesagt, die haben bei mir Pluspunkte gesammelt,
dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich erst mal mit Alma Linux rausbringen.
Aber wahrscheinlich waren die bei Rocky Linux ähnlich schnell.
Ich bin dazu dumm, das zu finden.
Ja.
Also finde ich es sehr nice, dass die vier Tage schneller waren als Red Hat.
Das musst du erst mal hinkriegen, oder?
Ich meine, Red Hat kriegt massig Geld für.
Red Hat ist fett im Business Enterprise Umfeld vertreten,
brauchen aber trotzdem vier Tage länger als ein kostenloser Red Hat Nachbau.
Da muss man doch echt mal
Hut ab
sagen vor
Alma Linux.
So, dann machen wir jetzt mal was, wenn wir hier gerade
Ich gehe mal auf den dritten
Ich starte mal kurz meine VM.
Da kann ich dir das nämlich zeigen.
Next Tag.
Ich hoffe, ich finde
die jetzt noch.
Weil die VM hatte ich
jetzt schon ewig nicht mehr an.
Da hatte ich nämlich ein Rust-Projekt drauf.
Hoffentlich finde ich das.
Wo man das sieht, wie schön man das statisch compilen kann mittlerweile.
So.
Repos.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Ne, hab ich auch nicht so verstanden, dass du was dagegen hast.
Ähm.
Ich wollte dir das bloß mal zeigen, wie es jetzt geht.
Das da?
Ist es das?
Run SH?
Agu?
Build SH?
Ja, genau.
Das musst du angeben.
Minus, minus, Target,
x68, 64, unknown, Linux,
Muse. Und es gibt
mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, dass du
nicht mehr OpenSSL verwenden musst,
sondern es gibt jetzt, ich glaube,
jetzt habe ich zu viele,
oh man, Chat, Leute, warte mal,
ich habe zu viele Sachen gerade offen.
Zu viele Desktops mit
Zeug drauf. Es gibt jetzt
Boring,
Boring SSL
Rust.
Das ist quasi
ein Rust Open SSL
Port und die meisten
Packages
also die meisten Rust Dependents
also die meisten
Rust Crates heißt, wenn man korrekt ist.
Also die meisten Rust Libraries
unterstützen mittlerweile Boring SSL
anstelle von Open SSL
und dementsprechend kannst du es auch
statisch compilen.
genau so ging das bild also abfangen muss es glaube ich eigentlich muss man einfach nur das
hier sagen minus minus tage vorher muss man das natürlich installieren sonst mecker darum
sind doch einfach irgendwas spannendes drin gewesen nee kann ist da koppel du warst das
nicht next tech habe ich dann habe ich euch gerade durch weil ihr habt bei mir fast die
gleiche farbe im chat ist halt das habe ich durcheinander gebracht
ok gut da mache ich die kiste mal wieder aus weil drei desktops mit drei
unterschiedlichen betriebssystemen drauf da hört bei mir dann auch
irgendwann mal im Kopf auf, wie ich da durchblicke.
Rocky Linux still affected?
Hä?
Ach, das ist was Neues, oder?
Ja, ich finde so irgendwie einen ordentlich durchsuchbaren Tracker ist echt schon wichtig, dass man das auf eine halbe Stunde suchen muss.
Jo.
Also Alma Linux muss ich echt sagen, fand ich echt nice.
Also ich habe es noch nie benutzt.
Also ich habe weder auf irgendeinem Server noch bei mir hier privat irgendwie oder bei Hetzner oder sonst wie.
jenen Alma-Linux entsteht. Aber wenn ich
mal wirklich was Red Hat-kompatibles
brauchen sollte,
würde ich wahrscheinlich Alma-Linux nehmen.
Können wir mal kurz gucken.
Seit wann es das gibt, eigentlich.
Also wir können jetzt ja mal hier sagen,
ähm,
in Bash
heißt es dann
Alma-Linux
und dann
Das kann man was schütteln.
Ich weiß nämlich gar nicht, wie lange es das gibt.
Das gibt es bestimmt noch nicht.
Also ich weiß, das gibt es erst seit CentOS nicht mehr CentOS.
Genau, seit CentOS nicht mehr CentOS ist.
Aber wann war denn das?
Vor fünf Jahren oder so?
Gibt es da irgendwie eine Übersicht?
Versions oder sowas?
Alma Linux Versions?
Also was haben die? Alma Linux 8, 9 und 10?
Für was braucht man ein Red Hat kompatibles Linux?
Naja.
Also ich kann dir einen Anwendungsfall sagen, den ich aus der Praxis kenne.
Wenn du
Nicht möchtest
Warte mal, lass mich erstmal kurz diese eine Sache hier fertig gucken
Also die haben einen Alma Linux
Okay, die haben 8, 9 und 10
Alles klar, okay
Also, die Frage ist
Wofür braucht man eine Letterskommunikation
Also, ich kann dir ein Beispiel nennen
Aus der Praxis
Wo wir das früher benutzt haben
Das war zwar noch CentOS, aber ist ja egal.
Letztendlich Red Hat-kompatibel.
Oder sagen wir mal, Red Hat ohne Red Hat.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du keinen Bock hast,
für jedes deiner Systeme Lizenzgebühren zu bezahlen bei Red Hat,
aber du eine einheitliche Umgebung haben möchtest.
So.
Und man könnte so weit gehen,
Da sage ich natürlich nicht, dass wir das gemacht haben oder so.
Könntest du auch so weit gehen und sagen, du kaufst dir drei, vier Systeme, du kaufst dir quasi von jeder Hardware-Ausstattung ein System mit Red Hat Lizenz.
Alle anderen Systeme lässt du mit Alma Linux laufen.
Und wenn du dann Support von Red Hat brauchst, dann haben halt zufälligerweise immer die Systeme, die du offiziell lizenziert hast, Probleme.
und nicht die einmal linux systeme
das sind dann zwar ganz schön fehleranfällige server aussicht von red hat aber das gehört
es zu machen und selbst wenn du das nicht machst wenn du einfach nur eine einheitliche umgebung
haben willst wenn du sagst ich brauche red hat zum beispiel für irgendwelche business enterprise
software also gehen wir mal von aus du du betreibst die was ich 50 jungs
kisten so dass er sich so viel ist auch überschaubar
fußstellung kisten aber das ist schon so ist es zu viel dass ich da dass ich
alles da immer von hand machen würde so und du sagst okay ich mache mir jetzt
einfach so 23 ansible playbooks um die sachen zu installieren die man also
braucht aber du hast halt kein bock deine ansible playbooks anzupassen dass
sie auf dem jan funktionieren dass sie auf rettet funktioniert dass sie auch
überall wirklich das gleiche machen aber du brauchst sagen wir mal für oracle
datenbanken oder irgendwelches andere business enterprise zeug brauchst du
halt ein paar offizielle red hat kisten die auch lizenziert sind
stellst du hin aber deine anderen linux systeme letztes halt gerne einheitlich
und da sagst okay wir entscheiden uns dafür machen dass red hat kompatibel und
Was PG bedeutet meistens?
Post-Crest, oder?
Ne.
Also, QA kann ich mir was darunter vorstellen.
Das ist quasi Testumgebung.
Oder Integrationsumgebung, wie das
automatisch heißt. Ach, Playground
heißt was bei euch.
Okay.
Finde ich witzig. Ich habe da schon die
unterschiedlichsten Namen für gehört.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit
ist es ein bisschen cursed.
Nicht so cursed wie auf der alten Arbeit,
muss ich dazu sagen.
Das kann ich vielleicht auch nochmal gleich erzählen.
Muss ich mal aufschreiben.
So.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit ist es ein bisschen cursed,
was die Umgebungsbezeichnung angeht.
Also, prinzipiell
haben wir
so die klassische Sache aus
Entwicklung,
Test,
Integration, Produktion.
Manche Umgebungen, also die sind nicht unbedingt
Pflicht. Das gibt es, das sind so die
vier Stages, die du auch in einem Dropdown
auswählen kannst, aber
du brauchst das nicht unbedingt. Also wenn du sagst,
ich brauche keine Dev-Umgebung,
weil da nichts gedefft
wird, dann kannst du die auch weglassen.
Das ist doch schon okay. Also diese vier Stages
gibt es erstmal.
Entwicklung,
Test, Integration,
Und Produktion.
Und jetzt ist das Problem, weshalb das...
Arbeitst du bei einer Bank?
Nee, ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Aber ich habe davor bei einer Bank gearbeitet.
So, und was ein bisschen cursed ist...
Ähm...
Die waren so schlau...
Und haben die...
Entwicklungsumgebung...
Lokal...
Entwicklung genannt.
Also, es gibt nicht eine Entwicklungsumgebung.
Ja, ich meine so die Stage-Entwicklung.
Heißt Lokalentwicklung, nur dass sie es in der Cloud in den Projekten Dev genannt haben.
So, und jeder, der jetzt irgendwelche automatischen Auswertungen macht oder irgendwas automatisiert, muss immer ein If einbauen.
Ist es Dev oder ist es Entwicklung?
Das ist echt cursed.
Das ist richtig nervig.
Aber das ist nix gegen das, wie es bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber war.
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber war die Umgebungsbezeichnung Ultra, also wirklich Ultra-Cursed.
Und zwar, da war es prinzipiell auch so, es gab eine Entwicklung, es gab einen Test, es gab eine Integration, es gab eine Produktionsumgebung.
Aber das war historisch gewachsen.
Die haben angefangen damals mit einem Produkt.
Mehr hatten die nicht.
Die haben quasi ein Produkt gehabt, angeboten und dieses Produkt gab es ursprünglich nur als Produktionsumgebung.
Also die hatten quasi Produkt A, Produktion, sonst hatten die nichts.
Also das war zu den Zeiten, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe für die Bank damals.
So, das gab nur Produktionsumgebung.
Okay.
Irgendwann kam dann einer auf die Idee und hat gesagt,
Leute, Produktionsumgebung alleine ist vielleicht auch nicht so schlau.
Wir sollten das Ganze nochmal aufbauen, dass wir die Sachen testen können,
bevor das dann immer kaputt geht.
Also gab es dann eine Testumgebung und eine Produktionsumgebung.
So weit, so gut.
Dann kamen sie auf die Idee, wir müssen ja unsere Mitarbeiter mit der Software schulen können.
Deswegen bauen wir neben der Produktionsumgebung noch eine Schulungsumgebung.
Und jetzt hat man den großen Fehler gemacht und hat die Schulungsumgebung nicht als zweites Produkt eingeführt,
eingeführt, sondern
als weitere Stage
der eigentlichen Anwendung,
was überhaupt keinen Sinn macht.
Ja, man hätte
sagen müssen, wir haben zwei Produkte
oder zwei Services. Wir haben
einmal unseren, was weiß ich,
ich nenne es jetzt mal irgendwie was,
unseren Dokumentenservice
und unseren Dokumentenservice
Schulung. So, die zwei
Sachen hätte man sagen müssen. Nein, was hat
man gemacht? Man hat es quasi als
weitere Stage des Dokumentenservice hingestellt.
So, und jetzt habe ich mal eine Frage an euch. Man hatte dann quasi
die Umgebung, Test,
Produktion, Schulung.
Wie würdet ihr jetzt eine Umgebung nennen,
die
die Schulungssoftware zu Testzwecken anbietet?
Da sind sie schnell auf die Idee gekommen,
wir nennen das ganze Ding Testschulung.
Und jetzt hattest du das Problem,
du hattest eine Test,
du hattest eine Testschulung,
und in Produktion hattest du eine Produktion
und eine Schulung.
Das heißt, du hattest immer das Stage drin,
außer bei Schulung,
und das andere, das war schon echt cursed.
Und dann haben sie es komplett kaputt gemacht.
Dann haben sie es komplett kaputt gemacht.
Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir brauchen das zur besseren Unterscheidbarkeit,
müssen wir immer noch das Produkt da irgendwie dran schreiben.
So, und dann, und dann, ohne Scheiß, ja,
dann kamen dann solche Dinger bei raus.
Zumindest, sie haben dann gesagt, okay, wir behalten das bei.
Das heißt dann quasi Dokumentensystemproduktion, Dokumentensystemschulung. Das Dokumentensystemschulung war quasi die produktive Schulungsumgebung des Dokumentensystems. Aber noch viel besser ist, wie hätten wir jetzt die Testumgebung nennen sollen?
Und dann hießen diese Umgebung
Allen Ernstes, Leute, ich
Wie hat der Asitoni gesagt? Ich lüsch net
Alles, alles
Das war so
Dann hatten wir eine Testumgebung, die hieß
Testproduktion
Und Testschulung
Das ist richtig cursed, oder?
Testproduktion, Alter
Das ist so hängen geblieben, man
Die Testproduktion, Alter.
Und da gab es dann wirklich Leute, die haben dann gesagt, ja, in Testbrot.
Und Leute, die neu da waren, die haben gesagt, was ist denn eine Testbrot?
Warum braucht man überein eine Testumgebung für die Schulung?
Na, weil das zwar im Kern die gleiche Software ist, aber mit komplett anderer Config und irgendwelchen Hilfetexten in der Software und hast du nicht gesehen.
Die hat das unterscheidet, das unterschied sich schon.
Also im Prinzip hätte man von Anfang an sagen müssen, es gibt zwei verschiedene Sachen, die wir anbieten.
Wir bieten einmal Dokumentensystem an und Dokumentensystem-Schulungssoftware.
So hätte man es von Anfang an machen müssen.
Wie oft wurden da Dinge auf Produktion gespielt, die eigentlich auf Test sollen?
Fällt mir jetzt gar nicht ein, dass das überhaupt passiert ist.
Wir haben uns da immer nur betrubelustig gemacht, aber gewusst hat es trotzdem jeder.
Oh, ich habe gerade was getrunken.
Exzellenter Hinweis, Chat.
Pfeifhead.
Ach ja.
Da gibt es schon immer abgedrehte Sachen.
Gibt es eigentlich ein Updates zu PW-Safe auf der Arbeit?
Ja, alles umgestellt.
Ich habe meine Saves mit meiner Software konvertiert.
Wie die anderen das gemacht haben, keine Ahnung.
Prebrot finde ich auch eklig.
Ganz ehrlich, ich mag das, wie wir es aktuell auf der Arbeit haben.
Entwicklung, Test, Integration, Produktion.
Das finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht.
er sagt hier einfach hier error free programming efe error free problem wenn
du keine fehler machst ja wenn du wenn immer alles fast drei funktioniert du
sparst dir ganz viel testsysteme dokumentation kommentare alles einfach
nie fehler machen
So.
Chat, ich muss nochmal kurz pinkeln.
Ich glaube, ich habe zu viel getrunken vorhin.
Ich bin gleich
wieder am Start.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
wieder da leute ich muss euch mal sagen ich liebe meinen klo ist einfach die beste investition
gewesen neben meinem bürostuhl einfach beste leute ja der da warum kriegt warum wird warum
habe ich hier das Icon vom Lost?
Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn.
Okay, whatever.
Ähm.
Ja.
Beste.
Der Klo hier.
Mit.
Guck.
Mit Spülung.
Ja, mit Spülung.
Guck, da kommt jetzt
der...
die Düse rausgefahren,
wenn man da drauf drückt.
Okay, Düse.
Und dann, bam!
In the Bobbis.
Oder nicht in, an den Bobbis.
Das ist so angenehm.
Beste.
Also, das ist nicht ganz so krass,
das Japan-Klo, da hat beispielsweise
keine geheizte Brille
und sowas.
Aber der kann das Wasser
warm machen.
Das Wasser kann der.
Ja, ja, das kann der.
Das kann der.
So, habe ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen?
Ich habe mich seit langem drüber lustig gemacht.
Über irgendwelche Umgebungsbezeichnungen.
gibt es nicht diese ängste alternative open tofu heißt die opel tofu ist
genauso wie Nexta schon geschrieben hat,
ist ein Terraform-Fork
und
ich glaube,
Open Tofu
ist damals entstanden, weil
HashiCorp, das sind die Leute, die
Terraform programmieren,
weil die irgendwas
an ihren Lizenzbedingungen
geändert haben.
Ja, Simonos Handy
habe ich eigentlich immer dabei.
Das war doch das.
Die haben irgendwas in ihren Lizenzbedingungen geändert
und dann haben die Open Tofu gefolgt.
Und mittlerweile ist Open Tofu sehr beliebt.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit wird auch mittlerweile Open Tofu verwendet.
Anstatt Terraform.
Terraform ist outgefaced.
Aber ich meine, im Prinzip funktioniert der Terraform-Code
quasi genauso in Open Tofu auch.
Und dazu muss man noch sagen, dass Terraform bzw. Open Tofu eigentlich nicht wirklich eine Alternative zu Ansible ist. Also kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen drüber streiten. Ansible und Terraform haben schon eine gewisse Überschneidung.
Ja, und du kannst mit Ansible auch viel von dem machen, wofür du Terraform verwendest. Du kannst mit Terraform auch einiges machen, was du mit Ansible machst. Aber grundsätzlich muss man sagen, dass beides unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte hat.
Terraform wird meistens dafür verwendet, um Infrastruktur aufzubauen,
also zum Beispiel VMs zu professionieren bei einem Cloud-Anbieter oder um Kubernetes-Cluster-Datenbanken aufzubauen.
Und Ansible wird benutzt, um die VMs danach so einzurichten, wie sie eben sein müssen.
Also, wenn man komplexere Konfigurationen hat, dann ist die Kombination aus beidem durchaus sinnvoll.
Ja, dann sagst du, okay, ich habe jetzt hier meinen Terraform-File, ich baue damit 20 VMs auf und danach lässt du auf allen diesen VMs, kannst ja auch einen automatischen Job machen beim ersten Startup oder über CloudInit oder sonst was, lässt du einen Ansible-Job laufen, der dann die VMs einrichtet.
ja der dann zum guckt sind alle user da sind alle tools installiert sind alle
zertifikate trusted ach was auch immer was du halt auf deinen ganzen linux
servern haben willst das ist deutlich einfacher und angenehmer mit ernte bild
zu machen als in terraform weil terraform hat da eigentlich nichts für
bei terraform müsstest du dann halt irgendwelche skripte letztendlich laufen
lassen wobei ist wahrscheinlich auch einige
terraform provider gibt dafür aber in der regel kannst du sagen terraform ist
für den aufbau der infrastruktur ansatzbild ist für das kommt also zum
aufbauen von vms in dem fall und ansatzbild ist für das konfigurieren von
vms also infrastruktur terraform config ansatzbild wo es natürlich trotzdem
alper beiden überschneidungen gibt ja du kannst es gibt beispielsweise für
ansatzbild auch einen google cloud provider collect wie heißt das bei
modul bei uns ist modul da kannst du damit auch vor allem aufbauen aber
terraform ist da schon mehr für gemacht als ende will
deswegen am besten ist wenn man da komplexe anwendungsfälle hat man
verwendet einfach beides und mit terraform baut man seine infrastruktur
auf und mit Enzibel konfiguriert man dann die aufgebauten VMs.
Dankeschön für den Sub, McFly.
Pog Subscription.
Exquisite.
So.
Chat, ich muss mal gerade
meine Hose ordentlich richten.
So.
Gut.
Dann hätten wir das.
Chat, ich habe nichts geplant für den Stream heute.
Großartig, ne?
Ist Open Tofu auch für
Container Management gut.
Du kannst damit...
Also nee, ist es nicht. Um es mal kurz zu machen.
Oder was meinst du
mit Container Management?
Sowas anzulegen wie
einen Cloud Run oder
irgendeine
auf irgendeiner Managed Container Form
irgendeine Function ausführen oder sowas.
Das kannst du...
So Dinge anlegen kannst du gut
mit
mit Terraform machen.
Aber wofür Terraform nicht gut ist,
ist für Konfigurationen von einem Kubernetes-Cluster
oder Konfigurationen von VMs.
Also zum Beispiel, was du wunderbar machen kannst mit Terraform ist,
zu sagen, ja, das kannst du gut mit Terraform machen.
Also Cloud Run heißt das bei Google zum Beispiel.
Google Cloud Run.
Das kannst du wunderbar mit Terraform machen.
Ist das das Richtige?
Ja.
Genau.
Guck.
So sieht das dann in...
Hä?
Warum sieht das so kacke aus?
Ah hier.
Das suche ich.
das ist ja auch schon ekliger, aber das kannst du in Terraform machen,
kannst du sagen, hier, guck, Cloud Run,
Blah, Container, so,
dafür ist Terraform
gut, für solche Sachen, ja.
Aber um erstmal zurückzugehen,
was ich da eigentlich sagen wollte, also Terraform ist
auch wunderbar, um zu sagen, ich hätte gerne
einen Kubernetes Cluster,
und zwar mit diesen und diesen
Node Types,
und die
dinger sollen die not sollen so viel ram haben und ich will maximal vier notes
haben diese ip adress ranges für den cluster und sowas dafür ist terraform
wunderbar wofür terraform nicht so geil es ist wenn der cluster dann steht zu
sagen ja ich brauche dann noch einen manager drin das manager soll folgende
konflikt bekommen und dann brauchen wir noch hier eine message also so konflikt
von dem Cluster dann innen drin, also
quasi den Cluster benutzen. Das
geht, ja, es gibt ein CubeCTL
Plugin für Terraform und
auch ein paar andere Dinge, man kann das
machen, also man kann ja quasi
Kubernetes YAML
in Terraform irgendwie schreiben, mal ganz
ehrlich, nur weil das geht, heißt das noch
lange nicht, dass es eine gute Idee ist.
Da würde ich lieber was
anderes verwenden. Da würde ich mir dann
ein Git-Repo machen, wo meine ganzen
Kubernetes-Sachen als YAML-File drin liegen
und wenn man es automatisieren will, kann man es
immer noch mit Flux oder Argo CD machen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall die bessere Variante,
als seine Kubernetes
quasi Inhalt vom
Cluster noch irgendwie in Terraform
reinpressen.
Naja, Provider gibt es,
aber ich finde es trotzdem nicht sinnig.
Du meinst diese Geschichte, dass die Telekom extra Geld von Cloudflare will?
Gab es da nicht letztens sogar ein Urteil zu?
Habe ich da nicht irgendwas in den News gelesen?
Warte mal, lass mal kurz gucken.
Telekom Urteil. Ich habe doch letztens irgendwas gelesen.
Okay, oder auch
nicht.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Details kann, also ich kann es dir
also ich kann es dir technisch erklären,
ja, aber ich kann dir nicht
die
die genauen Hintergründe erklären. Dafür habe ich mich
nicht genau genug damit
beschäftigt, warum die Telekom
das macht.
und was damit Cloudflare läuft.
Weil so, die wollen irgendwie extra Geld für den Traffic von Cloudflare haben
und Cloudflare sagt, habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, so machen wir das aktuell auch.
Wir haben ein eigenes Terraform-Modul für Kubernetes-Klassiker, der installiert,
zert manager und sowas mit das machen wir auch über terraformer mir gefällt es jedes mal nicht
zum beispiel hatte ich letztens was dass ich bei dem engine x in press oder was schon gateway
ich wollte irgendeine option für den ingress controller setzen es könnte auch gateway api
gewesen sein soll egal und das ging dann nicht das war auch ganz aber nicht also
ich würde lieber kubernetes jammel in jammel belassen uns nicht in terraform
reinwurschteln muss man gucken wie es am besten passt
genau ich habe ihn scheitern freundin youtube video gesehen was ich gedacht
Das müssen wir uns mal zusammen angucken.
Genau, hier das von Kreativecke.
Tschüss Windows, darum wechsle ich dieses Jahr zu Linux.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ähm.
Hehe.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin der Meinung, es wird nie das Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben.
Sondern, dass es weiterhin so ein schleichender Prozess ist, wie es auch die letzten Jahre über war.
Ja, gerade das letzte Jahr hat das richtigen Knick nach oben im Graph gemacht, was natürlich auch unter anderem daran liegt, dass Microsoft es richtig hardcore immer weiter verkackt unter Windows und dass immer mehr Influencers auf die Linux-Geschichte aufspringen.
und das hat schon einen richtig großen Klick nach oben gemacht, das letzte Jahr über, was so die Linux-Verbreitung angeht.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem nicht, dass man sich daran ableiten kann, quasi jetzt wird es jedes Jahr 5% mehr Linux-User geben
und in so und so vielen Jahren sind wir dann alle auf Linux.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, ich gehe davon aus, das wird weiterhin ein langsamer schleichender Prozess sein
und
aber unterm Strich Linux trotzdem auch immer besser machen,
weil es ja oftmals so ein bisschen Henne-Ei-Problem immer war
mit Anwendungen und Sachen unter Linux.
Und ich glaube, das wird zunehmend besser.
Und was wir jetzt natürlich auch noch erwähnen müssen,
ist Valve hat natürlich auch einen riesen Anteil dran,
dass Steam unter Linux funktioniert
und mit Proton auch viele Spiele,
die gar nicht für Linux entwickelt werden,
auch easy funktionieren unter Linux.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, ein springender Punkt, der für viele auch noch ausschlaggebend sein könnte, ist,
sollten mehr Spielehersteller anfangen, Anti-Cheat-Sachen unter Linux zu unterstützen.
Was natürlich bei manchen Herstellern nicht auf viel Gegenliebe stößt, weil sie unter Linux nicht so viel machen können damit.
oder weil da nicht so viel akzeptiert wird wie unter Windows.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn...
Also du kannst ja unter Linux auch viel machen,
aber Chat, ich bin mir eigentlich bei Linux-Usern relativ sicher,
sobald die Kernel-Module installieren sollen,
also quasi sobald du Root-Rechte brauchst, um Kernel-Module zu installieren,
für ein Game, da hört die Liebe bei Linux-Usern auf.
Und das wird dann so wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
RF-Programmer ist am Start. Moin.
Dann schauen wir uns doch mal an, warum Kreativecke...
Ecke.
Ach, der zeigt,
das ist ein Video, wo er einfach nur Nubara zeigt
oder was?
Kernel-Level.
Okay, wir zappen da mal kurz
durch.
GeForce Now auf Linux, das geht mit
Moonlight.
Wir skippen mal
ein bisschen durch das Video. Schauen wir mal.
Aber das erste hören wir uns an,
warum er umsteigt und was er schon
für Erfahrungen gemacht hat.
PewDiePie, habe ich ja gesagt.
Ganz viele Influencers sind ja darauf aufgesprungen, auch ein bisschen.
Dieses Jahr werde ich wohl vollständig auf Linux umsteigen.
Und ganz ehrlich, noch vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich selbst gedacht, dass das schwierig wird.
Aber mittlerweile gibt es ein Betriebssystem, das sich für mich ganz persönlich wie die bessere Windows-Version anfühlt.
Und was dieses Betriebssystem...
Was bin ich hin?
...für mich ganz persönlich...
Das KDE Widgets gedöhnt.
Persönlich, wie die bessere Windows-Version anfühlt und was dieses Betriebssystem kann.
Warum nicht nur Gaming darauf unglaublich gut funktioniert?
Und ob es auch für euch eine echte Alternative darstellen könnte?
Lass uns mal schauen.
Also wie gesagt, das gucken wir uns nicht im Detail an.
Mich interessiert nur, was er sagt, was er bisher für Erfahrungen gemacht hat.
Und mich würde auch interessieren, was er zu Kernel-Level-Anti-Cheats sagt.
Ich weiß, was einige hier jetzt denken werden.
Linux ist ja schön und gut, aber das ist erstens was für Nerds und zweitens laufen Kernel-Levels.
Naja, das, ja gut, hat er recht.
... Anti-Cheat-Games.
Das, was er jetzt sagt.
Also ich glaube, dass Linux nur was für die Hardcore-Kellerkinder ist, hat sich mittlerweile rumgesprochen, dass das auch wunderbar so geht.
Gerade viele ältere Leute kommen auch gut mit Linux klar, weil wer keine Ahnung von Windows hat, hat auch keine Ahnung von Linux.
Und wer nur einen Browser aufmachen kann, kann das auch unter Linux.
Mein Vater verwendet seit Jahren jetzt den Linux Mint auf Minipc und seitdem gibt es keinerlei Support-Anrufe und sowas mehr.
Okay, die Kiste war jetzt auch schon länger nicht mehr online.
Vielleicht hat er sie mittlerweile aus dem Fenster geschmissen oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass Teamviewer sich ausgelockt hat.
Updatet er das System.
Der hat keine Root-Rechte und ich habe einen Auto-Update damals eingerichtet.
Das updatet immer automatisch.
Und es scheint keine Probleme gegeben zu haben.
Battlefield 6 darauf nicht.
Und naja, was ihr hier seht, ist Battlefield auf einem Rechner, auf dem Linux installiert ist.
Dazu kommen wir aber später.
Das streamt ja bestimmt von einer Windows-Kiste mit Moonlight oder so.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich letztes Jahr ungemein viel ausprobiert habe.
Ich hatte ein Riesenproblem mit Distro-Hopping.
hat jeder, der neu mit Linux anfängt.
Wirklich jeder.
Jeder. Und selbst ich.
Ich probier auch
immer noch neues Zeug gerne aus.
Und dann landet man dann irgendwann mal
bei so Sachen wie CacheOS.
Wenn man mal ne neue Kiste hat und sagt,
ey komm, ist gerade gehypt,
gucken wir uns mal an. Natürlich muss das dann auch
was taugen. Und schon bin ich hier auf
CacheOS unterwegs.
Weil es
mich dann doch überzeugt hat.
Aber ich habe auch jahrelang schon Arch verwendet.
...einfach nur genervt war von Microsoft und den ganzen Updates.
Andererseits, weil es wirklich Spaß macht, neue Dinge zu probieren,
Videos gemacht habe ich dann zu Beside, zu CacheOS.
Und Beside war mir mit der Zeit zu generisch,
obwohl es sich für Anfänger richtig gut eignet.
Und CacheOS ist enorm gut,
aber hat sich nicht ganz so intuitiv angefühlt.
Das stimmt wohl, das stimmt.
Und CacheOS wirkt tatsächlich noch ein bisschen, wie sagt man das auf Deutsch, kantig an den, ne, noch nicht ganz so geschliffen überall.
Was mich aber nicht stört, weil ich das meiste eh über das Terminal mache und dann vollwertiges Arch-Scheinungs drunter ist.
Ich finde es sogar mittlerweile angenehmer als offizielles Arch Linux, weil die haben noch zusätzliche Repos mit vielen Paketen, die ich sonst aus dem User-Repo installieren müsste.
Ein bisschen unpolished, ja. Gerade die GUI-Sachen. Aber brauche ich eh nicht.
Aber da ist es mir an sich schon fast lieber als nackiges Arch Linux, weil ich musste viele Sachen früher aus dem Arch User-Repo nachinstallieren,
die ich jetzt alle über offizielle Paketquellen gefunden habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe nur noch ein Package jetzt hier installiert über...
Wie macht man das überhaupt?
Wie guckt man sich... Das ist eine gute Frage.
List all our packages installed.
Pack-QM. Okay.
Oh, das habe ich.
Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt
Warum hab ich das installiert?
Weiß ich nicht
Okay, doch, ich hab noch ein paar Sachen über Arch User Repo installiert
Aber es waren früher noch mehr
Und viele Sachen hab ich jetzt halt
Über die offiziellen
Cache OS Depots auch gefunden
Die noch nicht in den offiziellen
Arch Linux Repos drin waren
Also find ich eigentlich ganz nice
Nackiges Arch hat nicht mal
Ne Window Manager, nö, nö
Hat's nicht
Nackisches Arch hat gar nichts.
Du kannst aber vieles schon mit installieren lassen, musst dich aber halt um die Konfiguration selbst kümmern.
Das finde ich übrigens auch sehr nice.
Das ist halbwegs sinnig vorkonfiguriert hier mit KDE.
Ich bin ja gleichermaßen auch umgestiegen von einem Tiling Window Manager.
Ich habe ja jahrelang war ich auf Arch-Stellungs mit I3.
Und ich bin jetzt quasi umgestiegen von einem Arch-Stellungs mit I3 auf einen Cache-US Arch-Stellungs mit KDE.
Wobei ich denke, dass KDE irgendwie immer noch wie mein Tiling Window Manager bediene
Werde ich auch weiter so machen
Warum nicht? Ja, einfach das Beste aus beiden Welten
So, gucken wir mal weiter
Und in meiner Distro-Hopping-Historie bin ich dann irgendwann hier drauf gestoßen
Nobara OS, was für mich erstmal wirklich wie der perfekte Kompromiss gewirkt hat
Nubara OS basiert auf der Linux-Distribution Fedora, die generell ziemlich modern und performant ist.
... bei Nubara haben die Entwickler vor allem darauf geachtet, dass das Ganze so attraktiv wie möglich für Gamer und Creator ist.
Und ich glaube, die wichtigste Voraussetzung dafür ist eine Integration von Nvidia. Ein Problem vieler Linux-Distributionen ist und war, dass sie keinen vorinstallierten Nvidia-Treiber haben.
Und, und, dass die Nvidia-Treiber kacke sind.
Die haben ja teilweise, Disclaimer, ich weiß nicht, ob es heute tagesaktuell immer noch so ist,
aber vor nicht allzu langer Zeit war es so, dass Nvidia-Grafikkarten sogar unter Linux teilweise 50% langsamer waren als unter Windows.
Also der Linux-Treiber ist nicht nur nicht vorenzählt, der Linux-Treiber ist auch scheiße.
Nobara hat aber sogar eigene Nvidia-ISOs für Nvidia-Grafikkartenbesitzer.
So, genug geredet. Ausprobiert habe ich es trotzdem mit diesem Ding hier.
Das ist mein Nachbau der Steam Machine.
Das Teil hat mit einem Ryzen 5 7500F, na RX 7600 und gerade mal 16 GB RAM jetzt nicht unbedingt die besten Specs und ich weiß, was ihr jetzt denkt.
Warum hast du das nicht mit einem dicken Gaming-PC mit Nvidia-Karte probiert?
Ganz einfach, weil dieses System die meisten Systeme, die Nutzer zu Hause stehen haben, viel besser repräsentiert.
Und ich hier eine entscheidende...
Und der kann sein fettes System mit Nvidia-Grafikkarte benutzen, um mit Moonlight Spiele, die unter Linux nicht laufen, auf Linux zu streamen.
Relativ lackfrei.
Also Moonlight an sich für Games ist das echt super.
Moonlight ist quasi...
Nvidia...
Dieses Nvidia Game Stream...
Nachgebaut.
Warte mal.
Moonlight ist der Client, Sunshine ist der Server?
War das nicht so?
Naja, Projektbenahme.
... Sache dran zeigen konnte, die gerade in der aktuellen Zeit der RAM-Knappheit und dieser absurden Preise zum Game Changer werden könnte.
Also habe ich Nubara heruntergeladen und mit Rufus einen Bootstick erstellt.
Dann die Boot-Reihenfolge im BIOS meiner selbstbauenden Steam-Machine umgestellt.
Weil da schon vorher natürlich ein Linux drauf installiert war, musste ich so...
Die richtigen Hackermans, die hätten natürlich DD'et direkt auf den USB-Stick.
Gibt es DD eigentlich auch für Windows?
Warte mal, DD for Windows?
Okay, mit WSL gibt es es dann auf jeden Fall, aber...
Okay, es gibt DD auch für Windows.
Ich habe mein Ventoy USB-Stick letztens überschrieben.
Weil ich den nie benutzt habe.
TPM und so weiter nicht deaktivieren.
Dann Nobara installiert, was übrigens denkbar simpel war,
wenn ich das Ganze mal mit der Installation von Windows vergleiche.
Jedes Mal diese tausend unübersichtlichen Punkte, bei denen man wählen muss.
Der Microsoft-Login und die nervige Werbung schon während der Installation.
Aber gut.
Und schon der erste Start fühlt sich völlig normal an.
Die Oberfläche ist richtig intuitiv.
und beim ersten Starten wird man auch direkt durch die ersten Schritte geführt.
Was ihr hier jetzt sehen könnt, es sind schon ein dicker Hau...
Chat, Chat, ich brauche die Linux-ISOs nicht auf dem USB-Stick,
weil ich mache eh keinen Support mehr bei anderen Leuten
und lokal habe ich meinen PXE-Server.
Guck, kann ich dir zeigen.
PXE-Boot.
Mal kurz gucken, dass das jetzt auch funktioniert.
Äh, zack.
PXE-Boot. Ich boote vom Netzwerk.
Und
nicht iVentoy. Selbstgebaut.
Guck hier.
PXE-Boot.
Und
mit Katze.
Ich kann
lokal booten, netconfig,
ich kann direkt weiter booten
zu netboot xyz, wenn ich
noch mehr brauche, ki generierte
Katze, ja.
Clonezilla, rescuecd,
rescuecd mit zfs, linux mint,
cache us, oder
meinen selbstgestrickten, ah ne,
den offiziellen Debian Installer
und
den letzten Debian Installer oder
meinen selbstgestrickten Debian Installer.
Meinen selbstgestrickten Debian Installer
finde ich ja persönlich mega nice.
Kann man nicht oft genug zeigen.
Bisschen selbsthuldigen.
Wir haben aber vieles zusammen im Stream
gebastelt dazu, muss man auch sagen.
Also ist nicht alles auf meinem Mist gewachsen.
Wenn ich einen Debian-Installer starte,
stellt euch mal vor, ich will mir einfach nur auf die schnelle
eine VM installieren. Die booten ja
standardmäßig schon PXE. Dann lande ich hier im Boot-Menü.
Sag Install.
Dann bootet der
einen Custom
eine Custom Init RAM FS bootet er.
Und dann kann ich Setup hier schreiben
oder einfach nur S oder was auch immer.
Und dann startet
der so ein Mini
Debian Installer, den ich selbst gebastelt
habe mit FZF.
Was willst du für ein Debian haben?
Unstable Testing oder Stable? Nehmen wir
Stable. Auf welche Festplatte willst du
das Ganze haben? Auf SDA.
Hostname von dem Ding?
Passt.
Und das war's.
jetzt wird Debian, das aktuelle
Debian Cloud Image drauf
auf die Disk
und mit einem Cloud Init
konfiguriert
beim ersten Boot konfiguriert sich das selbst
per Cloud Init
das heißt, so oder so ähnlich
haben das garantiert Läden wie
Hetzner und
ähm
Digital Ocean
oder was auch immer für ihre
Kisten auch
Ach ja, ihr seht es ja unten, ETH0, mir ist ETH0 immer deutlich lieber als ENS33.
Und ihr seht sogar, ich bekomme im Prompt direkt angezeigt, was das Ding für eine IP hat.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, ich brauche jetzt eigentlich mit dieser VM gar nichts mehr zu machen.
Die ist jetzt da, ich weiß, aha, 119.
Gehe ich auf die Linux-Kiste, ich hoffe, ich habe den SSH-Key jetzt hier.
äh, ssh root
at, äh, 119,
äh, ist übrigens
nicht root, es ist debian, was auch da
steht.
Debian,
zack, und schon
bin ich auf meiner neuen
debian cloud, cloud init
installierten VM drauf.
Das geht genauso schnell,
wie es bei Hetzner geht, und ich
wette mit euch, der
Weg dahin ist auch sehr ähnlich.
Nur, dass die Sachen bei Hetzner
natürlich nicht noch irgendein Custom-Installer laufen,
lassen wir es aber so komplett automatisch durchlaufen.
Da wählst du ja im Vorfeld aus, was ist.
Das ist sehr praktisch, weil normalerweise
musst du sonst den Debian-Installer booten,
den Debian-Installer durchklicken
und so hast du halt ein Standardsystem
mit IP, mit DHCP-IP
und
standardmäßig eingerichteten User
mit den SSH-Keys,
die ich hier verwende.
Und noch besser ist,
der macht auch
ein Up...
Nee, macht er nicht. Okay. Macht kein Update.
Macht aber auch nichts, weil ich das
neuste Cloud-Image einmal in der Woche runterlade.
Und ich dementsprechend
immer ein relativ aktuelles Debian hab.
Machen. Upgrade.
Ach, guck mal.
Der hat im Hintergrund
schon geupdatet. Genau.
Ja, und der würde auch...
Der ist auch so clever.
Und hat, ihr seht es hier, guckt mal, der hat OpenVM-Tools installiert.
Der erkennt nämlich, dass er in der VM ist und installiert dann OpenVM-Tools.
Verteilst du für PXE dann DHCP-Optionen oder weiß der Client, dass PXE zur Verfügung steht?
Ja, ich kann das Setup mal kurz
Ich zeig das Setup mal einfach
Weil mir das selbst so gut gefällt
Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter
Aber man blickt schon durch, ne
Also, wir locken uns jetzt mal auf die Kiste ein
Ich hab vergessen, was mein Raspberry Pi
Das läuft ja auf dem Raspberry Pi
Die ganze PXE-Geschichte
Ich hab vergessen, was mein Raspberry Pi für ein IP hat
Ich glaub 2.51
Ist der das?
Ne
5.5
äh
Max
der PXE Champ
da sind wir
zum Glück, zum Glück hab ich ja
so tolle User und Passwörter überall
also das ist der Raspberry Pi, wo das
drauf läuft, das erste
lädst du das Image manuell runter oder lässt du das
runterladen, such schon länger eine Möglichkeit
seine tatsächlichen Linien
aktuell zu halten, ok
Okay, mit was fangen wir an?
Okay, Sven, ich beantworte erstmal deins, weil das relativ einfach zu beantworten ist.
Ich habe hier ein Skript.
Und zwar war www.html installsh.
Nee, nicht installsh.
Isus?
Ich weiß mal wieder nicht, wo ich meinen Krempel hingelegt habe
Äh
Update.sh
Wo habe ich das hingelegt?
Okay, find
Update.sh
Ah ja, hier, hier
Ah, Install Image
So, also
Da liegt ein Skript
Update.sh
Puzzlemeister, dankeschön
Dankeschön für die
Subscription
StaticDNS
Na ja
Also ich hab hier ein Updatescript gebaut
Was
Einmal die Woche läuft
Guck hier, das liegt hier unter
Warum liegt das alles unter
www.html
Weil es ein Guide ist, wo man die Sachen am besten
Nicht hinlegen sollte
Nee, weil ich faul as fuck war
Und es da gebastelt
habe und nie umgelegt woanders hingelegt habe es gibt hier etc kronen weekly image update guckt da
steht es drin also er macht einmal sonntag sonntag nacht wird er das einmal aus so was das kippt macht
ist folgendes das macht ihr ein bisschen die barcadence dann hat es ein paar funktionen ab
der dba net blablabla und was der unter der haube macht ist für jedes betriebssystem ist das ja ein
bisschen anders wie du an das neueste iso kommst und das iso update für dba funktioniert folgendermaßen
das macht eine schleife über die dba distros also hier unstable testing unstable stable und testing
Dann guckt das auf dem offiziellen Debian-FDP-Server nach und kreppt sich dort den Codename der jeweiligen Distribution raus.
Also hier, der Debian-FDP-Server hat hier einen festen Pfad für SID-Stable-Testing.
Da liegt eine Datei, die sich Release nennt.
Da kreppt er sich den Codename raus, weil den Codename braucht man später.
Und dann lädt er sich das runter mit dem jeweiligen Codenamen, das aktuelle Cloud-Image.
Lädt er sich hier runter und dann entpackt er es und packt es neu als LZ4-Image.
Ich benutze LZ4-Image, weil LZ4-Image super schnell entpackt werden kann, also perfekt, um es über das Netzwerk zu übertragen und per DD auf die Festplatte zu DDen.
Mir geht es jetzt gerade wieder ganz gut.
Also das Image selbst ist ein TAR-XZ.
Ich will es ja möglichst schnell installieren können, deswegen mache ich aus dem TAR-XZ ein LZ4-Image.
Und das heißt, ich kann es dann schnell übertragen übers Netzwerk,
weil die Dateigröße immer noch relativ klein ist, weil es komprimiert ist.
Aber LZ4 lässt sich sau schnell entpacken.
Dementsprechend kann ich es auch schnell auf die Platte de-dehnen.
Genau, so macht er das hier für Debian.
Dann lädt er sich das neueste Netboot XYZ-Image runter.
Dann macht er was ähnliches für CloneZilla.
Hier macht er was ähnliches für System Rescue.
System Rescue.org, System Rescue von GitHub.
Für Mint macht er auch was ähnliches.
Der guckt hier, wie das letzte Stable Linux Mint heißt, lädt sich das dann runter.
Für Debian, macht er auf Debian Insta, macht er im Prinzip nochmal genau das gleiche.
Für CacheOS guckt er auf der CacheOS Webseite nach, wie das letzte CacheOS Stable Image heißt, lädt sich das dann runter.
ZFF Bootmenü auch so.
und das schiebt er dann halt überall dahin
die ISOs, wo die gebraucht werden.
Also das ist halt ein selbstgestricktes
Updateskript.
Es gibt da nichts Fertiges für.
Und jede Distro funktioniert halt auch ein bisschen anders.
Er lädt aber
jedes Mal runter, auch wenn du die aktuellste
Version schon hast. Korrekt!
Wenn ich schlau wäre,
würde ich das MD5
summen und gucken,
ob das schon da ist.
Und meine SD-Karte sparen.
SSD, äh, nicht SSD.
SD-Karte nicht so schnell kaputt machen.
Allerdings läuft das eh nur einmal die Woche.
Und das ist zu verkraften.
So.
Ich hoffe, man hat das verstanden.
Puzzlemeister, danke schön für den Sub,
weil ich nicht gesagt habe.
Sven, ich hoffe, man hat es verstanden.
Also, es ist ein Custom.
Wenn du willst, kann ich dir das auch irgendwo hinlegen, ne?
Also ich kann das auch irgendwie Pastebin oder so reinhauen.
Aber es ist halt was Selbstgestricktes.
Ja, aber ich habe es halt möglichst, möglichst, ja, fehlerresistent gemacht.
Also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass Debian hier diese Adresse mal ändern wird und ihre Distro-Namen ändern wird.
Aber ja, das kann immer jederzeit kaputt gehen.
Okay, warte mal.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Äh.
Moment.
Das Problem habe ich hier.
So.
Ich.
Wir machen das jetzt mal hier auf irgendein Pastebin oder so.
Was weiß ich hier.
Pastebin?
dem kommt man doch irgendwie sagen dass das ist egal dass es einfach nur text
konnte man nämlich sagen dass der bester
Nein Nein, PxE Champ wird kein Ding.
Okay, create new paste.
Da ist es, guck mal, da checkt es sogar.
Da checkt es sogar.
Ja, ist alles da.
Okay, dann...
Kann ich hier eigentlich was schicken?
Nee, das geht natürlich nicht.
Okay, ich hab ein Problem.
Ich krieg das hier nicht raus.
Chat, Chat, ähm...
LSE...
Kannst du dir das abschreiben?
Ich hab das Problem, dass ich aus der Linux-Kiste nichts rauskopieren kann
auf meinen anderen Rechner, wo ich den
Twitch-Chat hab.
Großes L,
großes S, kleines E,
vier kleines E, großes F,
kleines S, großes R.
Okay, Chat hat schon
gepastet, alles gut.
So, next.
Also das ist automatische Image-Updater.
Das ist gar nicht so das.
So, und jetzt kommen wir zur Frage
von
IQ.
Also wie funktioniert das Ganze?
Als erstes,
da hast du das ganz richtig erkannt,
braucht man
DHCP Optionen, dass das funktioniert.
Dafür habe ich eine
DNS Mask Conf.
Was man dazu
wissen muss ist,
es muss nicht zwangsläufig
oder ich hab mal ne Frage an euch
wusstet ihr
dass
wenn ein Rechner
sich DHCP
per DHCP ne IP holen will
es ist ja meistens nicht nur ne IP
man kann sich ja noch mehr holen von DHCP
man kann sich ja auch den Gateway holen
und den DNS holen und sowas
wusstet ihr
dass
auf einen
DHCP-Request
mehrere DHCP-Server
antworten dürfen.
Also es können mehr als ein Server
darauf antworten und es werden auch die Infos
aus mehr als einer Antwort berücksichtigt.
Das geht.
Also man kann beispielsweise
von einem DHCP-Server
die
IP-Adresse verteilen
und von einem anderen DHCP-Server
PXE-Options
verteilen. Das geht.
Und so mache ich das hier nämlich auch.
Mein DHCP-Server
lokal bei mir macht ganz normal
meinen MikroTik-Router, aber ich habe noch
einen zweiten.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Solange die sich nicht in die Quere kommen.
Ich habe noch einen zweiten DHCP-Server
laufen.
Und zwar
ein PXE-Boot,
der
macht kein DHCP,
der läuft quasi als Proxy,
das nennt sich bei dem Proxy
so, ja,
der verteilt keine IP-Adressen.
Der zweite DHCP. Du kannst das
übrigens auch, wenn du nur einen DNS machst, kannst du
natürlich auch alles auf deinem Primären da machen,
aber ich, mein
MikroTik-DHCP-Server kann das
ja alles gar nicht, was der jetzt hier macht.
So, also, das ist ein zweiter DHCP-Server, der antwortet auf DHCP-Requests, vergibt aber keine IP-Adressen.
Ja, dafür gibt er per DHCP PXE-Options raus.
So, und der setzt hier unter anderem Dinger, das ist super krasse Magic, ich hab ewig gebraucht, bis das funktioniert hat, ne.
Ähm, so.
Wichtig ist das hier.
denn es ist ja so du kannst ja den rechner booten mit bios oder mit efi theoretisch sogar
efi mit nur 32 bit das heißt du musst unterscheiden was du für einen pxe image
auslieferst also lieferst du einen efi pxe image aus oder lieferst du einen bios pxe
E-Image aus, um davon zu booten.
Und das macht er hier.
Der guckt quasi, ist im
DHCP-Request, ich nenne es jetzt mal
das BIOS-Flag gesetzt.
Das ist hier diese
äh, das ist Client-Arch
Byte
0.
Also wenn in dem Client-Arch-Byte
im DHCP-Request 0 drin steht,
dann ist, oder nix drin steht,
dann ist es ein BIOS-System,
steht da 6 drin, dann ist es ein 32-Bit-EFI-System,
steht da 7 oder 9 drin, ist es ein 64-Bit-EFI-System.
Weird Champ hoch 10, aber das habe ich mir nicht ausgedacht, so ist es.
Das guckt er sich an und dann guckt er, ey, ist es, das hier lassen wir jetzt mit dem IPXE, lassen wir mal weg,
dann guckt er, ist es ein x86-PC, also ein BIOS-System, das erkennt er hier daran, an den Optionen, die er hier oben gecheckt hat,
Ist es ein x86 PC, dann bootet vom BIOS-Image.
Ist es ein EFI-System, dann bootet vom EFI-Image.
Das ist wichtig, sonst funktioniert das nämlich nur bei dem einen oder bei dem anderen.
So, was liefert er jetzt hier für Images aus zum Booten?
Der liefert IPXE-Images aus.
Die Open Source Boot Firmware.
Also das, was ihr gerade gesehen habt, mit dieser Katze als Hintergrund,
das ist ein IPXE-Image, was ich selbst kompiliert habe.
Mit dem Hintergrund und allem.
Das liefert IPXE aus und bootet hier einmal das da per BIOS und einmal das hier für UEFI.
Wenn das dann gebootet ist, dann kommen hier auch diese Boot Options für IPXE zum Tragen
und dann landet man in dem Boot-Menü.
Dann geht es weiter.
War.
T-F-T-P.
Hier.
Der IPXE startet dann per diesem Skript.
Hier ist dieses Menü, was ihr eben gesehen habt.
Guck.
Netboot, Clonezilla, Rescue, T-F-S.
Übrigens, Sven, wenn du sowas ähnliches bauen willst.
Ich habe im Archiv den Stream, wo wir das zusammen eingerichtet haben.
Da kannst du dir das in Ruhe angucken.
Weil das ist jetzt Schnelldurchgang und keiner checkt es.
Aber ich zeige es trotzdem mal fertig.
Das ist quasi die Config für dieses Menü, was das IPXE dann anzeigt.
Das hier vorher ist Magic, um zu checken, ob man eine gültige IPXE, also eine kompatible IPXE-Version hat.
Der guckt hier zum Beispiel nochmal, bootet er von EFI, bootet er von BIOS, dann macht er weiter das und was auch immer.
Weil das brauche ich, weil beispielsweise Proxmox standardmäßig IPXE bootet, aber ein IPXE, was nicht neu genug ist.
Deswegen bootet er dann mein PX-IPXE aus dem Proxmox-IPXE.
Also ganz ehrlich, PXE ist übrigens voll Wissenschaft für sich.
Genau, so und hier unten sind dann die ganzen Einträge für die unterschiedlichen Linux-Distros drin.
Zum Beispiel hier mein Debian-Installer.
Muss man ihm sagen, wo er seine Init-ID herkriegt, wo er seinen Kernel herkriegt.
und die kriegt er letztendlich hier unter www.html.
Da liegt dieser ganze Krempel rum, die ganzen Images, die er sich da lädt.
Das wird dann auch ausgepackt unter der HW-Wendung.
Wenn ich bei Debian zum Beispiel reingucke oder bei Install-Image reingucke oder so,
da seht ihr hier liegen halt die ganzen Dinger rum.
Oder bei Mint können wir reingucken.
da liegt halt hier das ganze Zeug, was man zum Booten braucht
per PXE rum.
Und dann bootet er davon.
Und dann macht er noch ganz viel Magic
über CloudInit.
Wenn ich dir das jetzt aber zeige, dann
sitzt er noch eine halbe Stunde da.
Guckt dir am besten einfach
den Stream an. Oder wen es interessiert,
wie das genau eingerichtet ist,
guckt euch diesen Stream an.
Hier.
Ey Eventoy suckt.
Das ist viel nicer so.
Außerdem ist Eventoy
proprietär.
Hm.
Der Schuck.
Schuck Stream.
Tja.
Hier, da ist es doch.
Linux PXE Boot und Install
extremer FIFAD Stream.
Das da ist es doch.
Ah, das hat der Sinux auch gerade schon
gepostet im Chat. Okay.
Genau.
Kann das sein, dass das Archiv kaputt ist?
Oder sind wir gerade wieder an irgendeinem Traffic-Limit?
Zumindest da kannst du dir das angucken.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, wir haben gerade ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Archiv.
Ich glaube, das Archiv hat...
Ist gerade kaputt.
Es gab auch mal...
Ich glaube, das wird nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Max FPS, what?
Ne, das wird nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Ich weiß nicht, wer hat das eigentlich gemacht?
Ich finde es voll nice,
dass das jemand so lange
sogar
ehrenamtlich hier gemacht hat.
Ja.
Wenn du Glück hast,
manchmal hat Twitch ja noch
die Wots länger.
Schauen wir mal, ob es vielleicht das noch auf Twitch
gibt, das Wot.
Ne.
Das gibt es ganz knapp nicht mehr.
Da musst du mal gucken, ob die nächsten Tage das Archiv wieder funktioniert.
So.
Gut.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns aber mal das Video fertig an.
Da wird ja ewig jetzt hier...
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles beantwortet?
Beantwortet, was dazu gefragt wurde.
Warum nicht auf GitHub?
Oder weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin?
Wie ist die Konfiguration von dem Debian Cloud Image?
Deine eigene.
Ja.
Okay.
Das ist...
Okay, ich zeige es mal kurz, was das macht.
Okay?
Weil ich das...
Weil mir das so gut...
Selbst so gut gefällt.
Also.
Was das folgende...
Was das macht ist...
äh,
Config,
ich glaube, das da brauchen wir
jetzt.
Nein, ähm,
Config, ich glaube, das da.
Genau, das ist die Cloud-Init-Config
hier. Also, der hängt erstmal meine ganzen
SSH-Keys da an, dass ich mich danach einloggen kann.
Setze die
Zeitzone auf Berlin.
Disable root-Login.
Passwort
Expired nie
Er legt alle Default User an
Und dann macht er noch so ein paar
Dinger, übrigens, das ist jetzt
Ein schönes Beispiel für
Ähm
Wo man, bis wohin man
Terraform verwendet und ab wann Ansible
Auch wenn ich hier weder Terraform noch Ansible
Verwende, also das Aufsetzen
Der Kisten, ja, würde ich sagen
Alles Terraform, aber Config
Der Kisten
dass da der untere Teil, der würde dann normalerweise in Ansible reinkommen,
wenn man ein bisschen mehr als ein paar Skriptzeilen hat.
So, und das hier, diese Zeile da, sorgt dafür, dass der auf der VM,
weil ihr lädt es im Watt-Archiv, okay, top.
Und diese Zeile sorgt dafür, dass der OpenVM-Tools installiert,
wenn es auf einer VM-Werkkiste ist.
WirtWatt, Leute, falls ihr das nicht kennt, super Tool, immer sehr praktisch.
Virtual.
Das zeigt euch nämlich an,
auf was für einer Linux-Kiste ihr gerade unterwegs seid.
So, das hier ist jetzt eine echte Hardware-Kiste.
Virtual.
Ja.
Nix. Wir sind nicht virtualisiert.
Gehe ich jetzt hier per SSH drauf,
auf die Linux-Kiste, wo wir eben waren,
und sag, wird what?
Achso.
Wird what?
VMware.
Guck, der erkennt, weil das hier läuft ja.
Das ist ja hier die VMware-Kiste,
die ich euch eben gezeigt habe.
Also wird what? Checkt, auf was ihr seid.
Und wenn die Antwort ist
VMware, dann installiere ich OpenVM-Tools.
Wenn die Antwort ist KVM,
dann installiere ich den Kuemu-Guest-Agent.
Und das Allerwichtigste,
ich setze Wim als meinen Default-Editor.
und ein paar Standard-Configs und Zeug.
Sieht's aus.
So.
Ich hoffe, jetzt haben wir alle Questions
beantwortet.
Fall ich das Ding wieder aus?
Brauchen wir ja nicht.
Okay.
Weiter im Text.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt eigentlich nicht angucken,
was er...
Ach, wobei.
Komm, das Video geht nicht lang.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal komplett an.
Vorinstalliert.
By the way, übrigens auch so Sachen wie Steam.
Discord musste ich herunterladen, aber auch das ging problemlos und es fühlt sich insgesamt viel fertiger an, als so ein frisch installiertes Windows.
Also als erstes direkt...
Was? Wie heißt das Tool bei dir oben links, um zwischen den Desktops hin und her zu switchen?
Das da?
Das hier? Das ist KDE. Das ist ganz normales KDE.
So sieht KDE aus.
Achso, du kannst das in KDE...
Pager, oder?
Ne, warte mal.
Settings.
Workspace.
Virtual Desktops.
Das kannst du in den KDE-Settings einstellen.
Virtual Desktops, genau.
kannst du hier mehrere desktops hinzufügen und dann wenn du speicher ist dann hast du den dann
da und ich habe es mir halt so eingerichtet das kannst du dann short katz kannst du short katz
anlegen mit windows taste 1234 switch halt die desktops durch und diese switchen hier was du
da siehst zwischen der windows kiste und der linux kiste das funktioniert noch mal ganz anders das
ist auch ein bisschen durch die brust ins auge gelöst so dass ein schönes streaming setup ist
das funktioniert folgendermaßen ich habe unter windows wie ihr seht mehrere desktops guckt das
top 1 das top 2 das top 3 desktop 1 unter windows ist mein windows auf desktop 2 ist linux kommen
wir gleich zu wie das ist und die hatte ich noch vor immer auf aber das machen wir jetzt zu so
also ich habe mehrere desktops unter windows zwischen den ich umschalten kann aber ihr seht
wenn ich hier umschalte, jetzt kann ich nicht in der Linux-Geschichte klicken,
weil ich bin ja noch auf der Windows-Seite.
Deswegen läuft das Ganze folgendermaßen.
Das, was hier so aussieht, als wäre es ein Linux-Rechner,
ist eigentlich gar kein Linux-Rechner.
Das ist ein Linux-Rechner, der per HDMI an der Capture Card hängt
und es ist ein OBS im Fullscreen.
Es ist ein OBS im Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Windows-Desktop.
So, und dann habe ich mir einen Shortcut angelegt.
Jetzt bin ich auf der Linux-Kiste.
Und das ist, ich würde mal sagen, 99% der Weltbevölkerung werden nicht hier irgendeinen Delay merken.
So, und jetzt ist das folgendermaßen.
Ich habe hier per Capture Card den HDMI-Output ins OBS reingepackt. Wie das mit Maus und Tastatur geht, ist, ich habe hier ein Programm laufen, das nennt sich DeskFlow. Damit kann man zwischen Linux und Windows Maus und Tastatur sharen und bis zu einem gewissen Grad, dank Wayland, funktioniert es dann richtig, auch das Clipboard.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal zurückgehen unter Windows und ich gehe nochmal raus, hier habe ich Deskflow laufen. Das heißt, was hier eigentlich passiert ist, ich mache zwei Sachen. Ich switche mit Windows auf den zweiten Desktop.
dann drücke ich einen Shortcut, um per Deskflow meine Maus und Tastatur weiterzugeben.
Und wenn ich wieder zurück will, drücke ich einen Shortcut, um mit Deskflow meine Maus und Tastatur wieder zurückzugeben an die Windows-Kiste
und switche dann unter Windows den Desktop nach links und rechts.
So, nachdem ich keinen Bock habe, das aber jedes Mal von Hand zu machen und das mir auch zu langsam ist, habe ich in meiner Logitech Software hier einen Makro drin, was das macht. Guck, Makro, drück Shortcut für Deskflow und dann den Shortcut für Desktop umschalten.
und deswegen kann ich jetzt hier, wenn ich unter
Linux, wenn ich unter Windows bin,
einfach F2 drücken und ich bin in meiner Linux-Kiste
und wenn ich wieder F1 drücke, bin ich wieder in meiner Windows-Kiste.
Theoretisch könnte man sogar so
programmieren, dass es immer toggelt zwischen den
beiden Desktops mit nur einer Taste.
Darum brauchst du ein Apple TV, das würde mich
tatsächlich interessieren. Ich glaube bisher nämlich nicht,
dass ich ein Apple TV brauche.
Ist das nicht ein schönes Setup, Leute? Ich trinke mal was.
Big Brain Setup
und wie gesagt, das ist
nahezu, ich kann euch das sogar
demonstrieren, dass es lagfrei ist
weil mein Streaming läuft unter Windows
passt mal auf, wenn es laggen
würde
oder wenn es groß laggen würde
und wir machen das jetzt mit Audio
Maus und Tastatur gehen ja nochmal
schneller
dann müsstet ihr jetzt hier
ein Delay sehen
Video Sync Test.
Wir haben übrigens mal getestet.
Wir hatten es doch mal getestet.
Ich glaube, ich hatte 15
Millisekunden hatte ich Delay.
Das heißt, ich würde
jetzt keine competitive
Sachen spielen hier unter Linux.
Aber für ein
Desktop Setup sind 15 oder 10
Millisekunden Delay wirklich nicht die Welt.
Wir hatten das getestet hier mit
Human Benchmark.
Ja.
Human Benchmark
Reaction Time
Warte mal
Mal gucken
Heute bin ich ein bisschen pepega im Kopf
Mal gucken wie schnell meine
Reaction Time ist
Ups
Oh heute bin ich aber langsam
Heute bin ich langsam Leute
Okay
Okay.
Ich habe ein bisschen Anlauf gebraucht.
Also, 166 Millisekunden.
Human Benchmark.
Das letzte Mal haben wir öfters gemacht.
Der Seniorenklicker.
160 ist schneller als die meisten 20-Jährigen.
Und jetzt machen wir das Ganze nochmal.
Oh, ich habe die Maus nicht richtig in der...
Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen,
es ist schon ein bisschen, es ist schon ein bisschen Delay.
Okay, jetzt war ich super. Aber,
ja, es sind so 15, 20
Millisekunden Delay.
Ja.
Also ein bisschen Delay ist...
Okay.
Der war gut.
Ja, also ein bisschen langsamer ist man schon.
Wir können das Ganze jetzt nochmal mit Windows vergleichen.
Ja.
Also unter Windows bin ich doch eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Ich bin unter Windows schon eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Also ich nehme das zurück.
Das Delay ist doch eher so um 30, 30, 40 Millisekunden.
Aber zumindest, ich merke es nicht.
Das sind super, das sind richtig gute Reactions, Leute.
Was wollt ihr denn?
Das haben die meisten 20-Jährigen nicht.
150 Millisekunden.
Achso, Zoomer, nicht Boomer.
Oh, sorry, ich hab mich verguckt.
Okay, nachdem ich mich jetzt eingeklickt hab, machen wir es hier nochmal kurz.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, naja, also, sagen wir 20, 30 Millisekunden ist es schon.
Zumindest wenn man sich hier den Audio-Video-Sync-Test anguckt,
werdet ihr auch sehen, das ist eigentlich so gut wie...
Ne? Also ihr habt... Also es ist wirklich echt...
Also für das, dass das gecaptured ist
und dann auch per OBS
und so, das ist kein Ding.
Also ich bin komplett
zufrieden mit dem Setup. Wie gesagt,
Competitive Sachen würde ich so nicht spielen,
aber bei Mausbedienung und sonst was
hast du, du merkst keinen Unterschied. Das ist wie Native.
Wie wenn du dran sitzt.
und by the way, ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass das unter Linux
generell langsamer rendert, mit
dem Reaction Test
hast du inzwischen mehr RAM eingebaut? Ne, hab ich nicht
Geh doch zu IEM
Ja, das Problem ist, dass ich in den Spielen
Sack, nur weil man ganz gute
Reactions für sein Alter hat, heißt das nicht, dass man
automatisch gut in den Games ist.
Genau.
Also ich hab hauptsächlich
nicht Linux, weil ich das Setup hier top finde.
Ich kann einfach unter Linux das machen,
was ich unter Linux am liebsten mache, unter Windows das am liebsten mache,
was ich unter Windows am liebsten mache.
Streaming,
Thumbnails, Video
editieren und
Gaming.
Das mache ich halt noch unter Windows.
Den Rest mache ich eigentlich unter Linux.
Ja.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal wirklich das Video mal fertig.
Ich habe schon wieder,
ihr kennt das, ich sage immer, wir gucken Video fertig
und dann dauert das drei Stunden.
... direkt mal Steam gestartet, eingeloggt und angefangen Games zu installieren.
Und dann bin ich auch direkt auf eine Idee gekommen.
Das hier ist ein System am unteren Ende des Spektrums mit einem für heutige Verhältnisse mehr oder weniger größeren oder auch kleineren Manko, nämlich nur 16 GB Arbeitsspeicher.
Ich, ich, Leute, ich gammel hier auf, ich gammel hier auf 8 GB RAM rum auf dem Linux-Mini-PC.
Wenn aber Nubara hochgefahren ist und Steam im Hintergrund Spiele runterlädt, Achtung, sind gerade mal 3,3 Gigabyte belegt. Wie sieht das bei Windows aus?
Man muss übrigens auch dazu sagen, Linux RAM Usage ist immer so ein Ding.
Also selbst wenn jetzt hier steht, komplett alles used, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass du jetzt keine Anwendung mehr starten kannst.
Also Linux belegt ganz gerne mal RAM und gibt RAM auch wirklich dann erst nur frei, wenn es eine andere Anwendung required.
Da kann man jetzt nicht unbedingt so viel drauf geben.
Das gleiche System auch nur mit Steam aktiv im Hintergrund braucht unter Windows mehr als das Doppelte an Arbeitsspeicher, nämlich 7,2 Gigabyte.
Na gut, hat halt Microsoft mal Hard-Vibe-Coded wieder.
Und genau da kommt eben das, was Linux vor allem für Leute mit einem älteren System oder auch einem Einsteigersystem verändert.
Dadurch, dass diese Distributionen nicht vollgepackt sind mit Bloatware, die keiner braucht, sind sie einfach ressourcenschonend.
Wisst ihr, was übrigens auch Ressourcen frisst?
Alle möglichen RGB- und Peripherie-Programme und Softwares.
Die braucht ihr beim heutigen Sponsor mit der Shakun SGK55W eine...
Ah, eine Runde Sellout.
Muss sein, Leute. Ich war auch noch nie in einer Wüste.
Was ihr hier seht, ist der Cyberpunk-Benchmark unter Nubara OS.
Auf diesem System in 1080p, hohen Settings, FSR3 auf Auto, aber ohne Frame Generation.
Auf dem gleichen System mit frisch installiertem Windows...
Es ist immer wieder Zeit, ich muss mir demnächst mal wieder meine Genshin Impact Placement angucken.
Ich muss mich da immer so kaputt lachen bei.
...frisch installierten Treibern läuft das einfach signifikant schlechter.
Der Grund wird nicht zuletzt wahrscheinlich der sein, dass Windows als Betriebssystem einfach so viele Ressourcen frisst.
Und das eben bei so einem System auch ins Gewicht fällt.
Und Cyberpunk ist tatsächlich nicht das einzige Beispiel, bei dem das so ist.
Das hier ist Black Myth Wukong unter Nobara, was auch signifikant schlechter...
Das von ApoRed kenn ich nicht.
Was hat der dann gemacht?
Wahrscheinlich so null Bock, oder?
Kritischer Hase.
...unter einem frisch installierten Windows funktioniert hat.
Und zwar so viel schlechter, dass das Spiel unter Nobara diese magische 60 FPS Marke durchbricht,
die es unter Windows nicht schafft.
Ich habe auch noch andere aktuelle Titel.
Bitte guckt ihr das an. Das klingt, als wäre es heftig cringe, oder?
Okay, Chat.
Weil ihr seid.
Okay, weil ihr seid, okay?
Das wird jetzt aber bestimmt peinlich.
ApoRed Genshin Impact.
Das da?
Ist es das?
Geile, hohe Grafik.
Genshin Impact.
Oh Gott, das wird mega cringe.
Wo wir aber beim Thema Gaming sind.
Dieses heutige Video wird gesponsert von Genshin Impact, Freunde.
Genshin Impact, Freunde, sollten viele von euch kennen.
Es ist das meistgetweeteste Game auf dieser Welt.
Es ist ein Open-World-RPG.
Okay, richtig schön in Anime-Style, was ich brutal schön finde auf jeden Fall.
Es hat eine Top-Bewertung zum Beispiel.
Kaufe ich eben sofort ab.
Spiel ING 9 von 10.
Der Hintergrund ist top.
Eine feine Sache ist, es ist auf jeden Fall ein super schönes Spiel.
Es ist kostenlos.
Was es noch hat, ist eine extrem geile, hohe Grafik.
Ein multiples interaktives System.
Es hat sieben verschiedene Regionen.
Und ihr müsst euch vorstellen, die Regionen sind auch mal alle unterschiedlich geil.
Die haben unterschiedliche Kulturen, die haben einfach einen unterschiedlichen Vibe.
Das heißt, er hat mega viel Abwechslung.
Wo wir beim Thema Region sind, Freunde.
Es ist ein neues Update rausgekommen.
Und es ist eine neue Region dazugekommen.
Und zwar Sumi.
Ja gut, der liest das eindeutig ab.
Aber wo ist das Problem?
Und ihr wisst, was eine neue Region heißt.
Das heißt, ihr habt auch wieder neue Charaktere.
Hier zum Beispiel Kolai, Uri und Tignari.
Ihr habt auch ein...
Recht mächtig.
Ein neues Element.
Und zwar Dendro.
Ja, Genshin Impact hat verschiedene Elemente.
und hier auch ein neues. Also auch richtig
knackig. Ihr habt wieder schöne neue Gameplay-Erfahrungen.
Richtig schön.
Ihr könnt den QR-Code schön hier abscannen.
Ihr könnt auch gerne mal den Link in der Beschreibung abchecken.
Das Spiel ist wirklich
bulletproof, richtig sweet,
richtig schön. Das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
so schlimm ist das doch gar nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich,
mein Placement ist kein Deut besser.
Ja.
Ich hab das Spiel nie geredet und muss...
äh, nie gespielt und muss darüber reden.
Was, das 3-Minuten-Video?
Ist das besser?
Ja gut, das ist jetzt aber gefakt, oder?
Das ist jetzt aber nur besonders nochmal zusammengeschnitten.
Das war so.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich?
Was meint ihr denn,
wie in Videos teilweise rumgestottert wird
und dann nachher rausgeschnitten wird?
Also, so schlimm ist das jetzt auch nicht.
Also,
wie gesagt,
Mein Placement war auch nicht wirklich besser.
Aber ich finde, Mainz hat deutlich mehr dazu, animiertes Spiel auszuprobieren.
Haben sogar Leute extra im Stream geschrieben, Max Download läuft.
Also ich habe jetzt Schlimmeres erwartet, ehrlich gesagt, bei ApoRed und Product Placement geht schief.
So, aber jetzt das andere Video doch mal irgendwann fertig gucken.
Gaming Benchmarks, Nubara vs. Windows.
Ja gut, jetzt wissen wir, dass Linux ja oftmals ein bisschen schneller ist.
Wann kommt endlich Sellout?
Ich hab doch schon selloutet oft genug.
Aktuell mach ich zu wenig Videos, um zu sellouten.
Zu wenig Videos ist gut, keine.
Ich hab zum Beispiel Doom The Dark Ages ausprobiert.
Oder E-Sport Games wie Counter Strike 2.
Für dieses System gesprochen kann man sagen...
Ja, witzigerweise, CS2 funktioniert ja wohl ganz brauchbar, ne?
Trotz, trotz, äh, Anti-Cheat.
...dass Nubara tatsächlich immer ein bisschen besser performt hat.
Aber ich weiß, was ihr jetzt denkt.
Das bringt ja gar nichts, wenn man nur Steam-Spiele spielen kann.
Doch kann man nicht nur.
Und ja, es gibt enorm viele Leute, die haben beispielsweise auch Games bei anderen Launchern.
Und es gibt hier für Linux den Heroic Game Launcher, mit dem ihr unter anderem auch Spiele aus eurer Epic Games Bibliothek installieren könnt.
Heißt also, auch das ist mittlerweile unter Linux möglich.
Aber ja, es gibt noch diesen einen Elefanten im Raum und das ist wirklich der Elefant im Raum.
Kernel Level Anti-Cheat.
Denn eigentlich sollen Spiele wie Fortnite nicht unter Linux laufen.
Was ihr hier aber seht, ist wie ich Fortnite spiele auf dem Rechner.
Ja, ich wette mit euch, das hat er per Moonlight gestreamt.
By the way, habt ihr auch gelesen, Epic hat wohl ganz viele Leute entlassen, weil Fortnite nicht mehr so gut läuft wie früher?
Schon einen Monat her.
... für mich durchbrochen werden musste, damit ich auf Linux komplett umsteige.
Das Stichwort heißt nämlich Cloud Gaming.
Und bevor ihr jetzt in den Kommentaren anfangt wütend zu feuern, ich gehöre selbst zur Fraktion, die lieber besitzt als mietet.
Und ich weiß, was ihr jetzt denkt, ist doch auch unspielbar wegen Latenzen und Co.
Und in diesem einen Punkt, da gebe ich euch auch recht.
Wenn man wirklich kompetitiv Fortnite spielt, dann würde ich sämtliche Quellen, die die eigene Performance behindern könnten, versuchen zu eliminieren.
Aber was ihr hier seht, ist Battlefield.
Und ich sage es euch ganz ehrlich, das hat sich für mein Gefühl gar nicht unterschieden von einem Rechner, auf dem das Spiel direkt läuft.
Denn jetzt kommt das Geheimnis dahinter.
GeForce Now ist seit Januar 26 für Linux verfügbar und auch unter Nubara nutzbar.
Ja, sogar Nvidia hat verstanden, dass momentan ein kleiner Umschwung auf Linux stattfindet.
Ich hab das zuerst mit...
Ach, es gibt das mittlerweile offiziell für Linux?
Ach nee, das ist Nvidia, ach das ist, das ist dieser Game Stream Service von Nvidia, ne?
Das lokale Game Streaming gibt es bestimmt nicht für Linux.
Aber dafür gibt es ja Moonlight.
Diesen kostenlosen Planversuch unter uns, das ist wirklich nicht geil.
Also es ist wirklich nicht geil.
Erstmal ist man in so einer Warteschlange und dann hat man in der kostenlosen Version immer wieder diese nervigen Mikro-Ruckler.
Bei der kostenpflichtigen Version war es wiederum was ganz anderes.
Damit startet das Game unmittelbar und ich war im positiven Sinne erschrocken davon,
wie flüssig das Spielerlebnis insgesamt einfach war.
Und rein was das Spielen angeht, ist damit für mich die letzte Barriere gebrochen.
Klingt blöd. Ich meine, ich spiele selbst gar keine Kernlevel-Anti-Cheat-Games.
Aber sollte ich mal Lust haben, dann greife ich lieber auf Cloud-Gaming zurück,
als wieder in Windows reinzubooten.
Aber auch hier weiß ich, was viele von euch denken.
Ich brauche den PC nicht nur zum Zocken, sondern auch zum Arbeiten.
Was ist mit den Leuten?
Wie ist die Latenz bei sowas im Multiplayer?
Also...
Erinnert sich vielleicht noch jemand hier dran?
Man erkennt es jetzt nicht richtig.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Das war das Game Streaming von Google, wo sie ganz fettes Werbung gemacht haben und haben eine Sache dabei gesagt, nämlich sie hätten sogar Negativ Latency.
Da waren wir uns natürlich alle einig, das ist Bullshit. Google hat es damals so erklärt, dass sie ja quasi alles bei sich auf dem Server laufen haben und wenn dann zwei Spieler Multiplayer miteinander spielen und sie laufen quasi bei Google im Rechenzentrum, dann haben die ja weniger Latenz, wie wenn beide von daheim spielen würden.
Gut, dass der Input und der Output noch hin und zurück muss, haben sie da nicht in der Rechnung mit eingezogen.
Das war kompletter Blödsinn.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, Latenz.
Ich habe, gleich Disclaimer, ich habe Nvidia Game Stream nie ausprobiert.
Was ich ausprobiert habe, ist das lokale Nvidia Game Stream.
Drüben im Wohnzimmer am Fernseher und per Moonlight.
und da muss ich ehrlich sagen
man merkt
man merkt eigentlich nicht den Unterschied
aber
nichtsdestotrotz
wenn ich irgendwelche Multiplayer
PvP
Spiele spielen würde
dann würde ich
die nicht über Streaming spielen
da würde ich die immer nur lokal auf dem Rechner spielen
ja
Und das müssen jetzt keine super krass Competitive Games sein, also muss jetzt kein Rainbow Six oder Counter Strike, Fortnite, whatever spielen.
Mir würde es persönlich auch schon bei Battlefield auf den Keks gehen, dass ich ein minimales zusätzliches Delay kriege.
trotzdem glaube ich
dass man die Latenz
tatsächlich etwas überschätzt
die sowas hinzufügt
ich will da mal was zu zeigen
und zwar
gehen wir mal davon aus
man spielt mit 60 FPS
äh nicht mit 60
mit 60 Hertz
Bildrefreshrate
Das heißt, 16 Millisekunden liegen da zwischen jedem Frame.
Bei 240 sieht das wieder, aber wir machen es mal mit 60.
Da kann man das Beispiel besser machen.
16 Millisekunden liegen bei 60 Hertzmonitoren quasi so zwischen den Screen Refreshers.
16 Millisekunden
Netzwerklatenz
ist ganz schön lang.
Also ganz schön große
Entfernung kannst du da zurücklegen.
Also von
also in 16 Millisekunden
müssen wir mal gucken,
80% der Lichtgeschwindigkeit, keine Ahnung,
wo du in 16 Millisekunden hin und zurück bist.
Also
das ist Netzwerklatency,
ist das gar nicht so wenig, ja.
Ich meine, im Vergleich zu früher ist das
nix. Früher hast du teilweise CS 1.6
mit 150 Millisekunden Ping
über ISDN gespielt,
aber man sieht schon, in 16 Millisekunden
kannst du eine ganze
Strecke netzwerktechnisch
zurücklegen, was du sonst zwischen
zwei lokalen Screen Refreshes hättest.
Ich glaube, die Latenz wird
da teilweise echt ein bisschen überschätzt.
Nichtsdestotrotz, also für
Spiele an sich, ja, für Spiele
an sich. Wir können ja mal hier kurz, wir können ja
mal KZK-Chats verfahren. Gucken hier.
Ping 8888.
11 Millisekunden.
9, 6, 7.
Schwankt ein bisschen.
Also hier, 7 Millisekunden.
Zum Google DNS, da steht höchstwahrscheinlich in Frankfurt,
würde ich mal drauf tippen.
Ist das
nix. Also,
das ist quasi die Hälfte
von einem Screen Refresh bei 60
Hertz. Also,
das wird glaube ich sehr überschätzt
was diese Latenz, was die Netzwerk-Latenz
da wirklich ausmacht, bei Spielen.
Wo sie meiner Meinung nach
trotzdem
indiskutabel ist, ist wenn du
PvP-Sachen spielst.
Ja, also wenn du, ich würde auch schon
bei Battlefield nix spielen,
über Stream.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so, wenn die Leute,
früher haben die Fall Guys gespielt, oder hier,
oder Sass,
oder was auch immer
da für Games, wo es halt null
auf Latenz ankommt,
dann kannst du das ohne Probleme spielen oder Singleplayer-Spiele oder irgendwelche...
Du kannst da bestimmt auch so Sachen, wenn du gerne Strategie-Games spielst und so.
Angenommen, du spielst Warcraft 3 oder sowas über das Battle.net oder über...
W3C heißt das andere, ne?
Da kannst du das bestimmt auch darüber spielen.
Aber so Competitive-Shooter, wo es rein auf Reactions, Latency und sowas ankommt, da würde ich es nicht machen, selbst wenn es nicht so wirklich spürbar ist, denkst du dir bei jedem Tod, ich bin jetzt wegen Latency gestorben. Und allein schon deswegen würde ich es nicht machen.
und wie gesagt, bei allem
wo es halt wirklich um
Reactions und PvP
gegen andere Spieler geht, da
würde ich es nicht machen, also ich würde bei Battlefield 6
würde ich beispielsweise auch immer
auf meiner Windows-Kiste spielen
und nicht irgendwie gestreamt auf
der Videokiste
aber wenn man
das nicht spielt
kann man denke ich
alles easy über Game-Streaming
spielen
und
Ich kann euch sagen, ganz normale Office-Geschichten funktionieren wunderbar, auch mit den kostenlosen Alternativen.
Ich habe sogar versucht, mit Microsoft Office erstellte Tabellen...
Und dazu kommt ja, man braucht das noch nicht mal.
Die meisten Leute haben ja ein Microsoft 365 Abo und die Cloud-Varianten von Excel und Word funktionieren ja wunderbar unter Linux auch im Browser.
Ein paar Sachen gehen damit nicht, aber ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal, das meiste davon, was da nicht geht, benutzen die meisten Leute eh nicht.
Also Office ist auch vollkommen fein.
PowerPoint kann aber kein Folienmaster. Was ist denn ein Folienmaster?
Wie unser Benchmark-Diagramm-Template zu öffnen und zu bearbeiten.
Das funktioniert einwandfrei unter dem vorinstallierten Liefer...
Nummerierung und Footer und so.
Okay.
Also ich habe schon ein paar PowerPoint-Sachen für die Arbeit gemacht.
Das habe ich tatsächlich alles im Browser gemacht mit Office 365.
und es ging danach genauso gut wie wie sonst also ja aber wahrscheinlich haben
das hat das dann da gefehlt ja kann sein
da hat ein kollege aber ich glück gehabt so gucken wir mal was er sagt zu seinem linux
umstieg ich persönlich wobei mich interessiert tatsächlich noch was er weil er macht ja auch
Videoschnitt und sowas. Unter Linux gibt es ja glücklicherweise, was
Videoschnitt angeht, mittlerweile eine Alternative, wenn man sich damit
auseinandergesetzt hat. Kann man da DaVinci Resolve benutzen.
Unsupported GPU Processing Mode.
Aha, das letzte Mal hat es noch funktioniert.
Und jetzt?
Startet es jetzt, oder?
Ne.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Was muss man da jetzt machen?
Was macht man jetzt, damit es wieder funktioniert?
Okay.
Anscheinend kann ich meine GPU hier nicht mehr auswählen
Das ist auch geil
Tja
Pech gehabt
Wir hatten es doch schon mal hier gestartet
Ähm
Könnte das sein?
Ne, aber ich hab 4 Gig
Ach, keine Ahnung
Ich brauch das eh nicht hier für Videoschnitt drauf.
Aber es würde mich interessieren, wie er das macht.
Man könnte auch jetzt dieses EU-Office oder sowas, das es da gibt.
Hat das schon mal irgendjemand von euch verwendet?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt.
Euro-Office?
Euro-Office.
Euro Office
Wo gibt es das eigentlich?
Gibt es das irgendwie zum Download oder so?
Zur Ausführung von Euro Office ist Java
Nein, das glaube ich jetzt eher mal nicht
Gibt es das auf GitHub?
Hier.
Euro Office.
Die haben noch nicht mal
ein ordentliches Bildchen.
Da würde ich, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde den hier noch nicht mal,
ich würde, wenn ich das sehen würde,
würde ich noch nicht mal davon ausgehen,
dass das hier überhaupt
das Offizielle ist.
Also keine Ahnung, ist das...
Ja.
Also ich würde nicht denken, dass das hier das offizielle Repo ist, ganz ehrlich.
Naja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder so
Totgeburt dann, was sie da
fabrizieren.
Microsoft Office Dokumenten hat.
Und dann gibt es noch haufenweise kostenlose
Alternativen zu Tools, mit denen
ich selbst oder auch Leute, mit denen
ich täglich zusammenarbeite,
arbeiten, wie zum Beispiel Blender.
Eine kostenlose Alternative zu Photoshop wäre Gimp.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten, weil sich das Gimp immer viel Hate abbekommt.
Die können das Ganze ruhig forten.
Ich hab da überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Aber wenn man halt was entwickelt, hat man ja auch schon so ein bisschen den Hintergedanken,
das soll sich auch mal verbreiten.
und so wie ich das da gerade auf GitHub gesehen habe,
ich weiß nicht, also das sah jetzt nicht so
einladend aus, als will ich mir das installieren.
Ja, das ist bestimmt irgendwie so eine
Todgeburt, redet in dem Jahr keiner mehr von.
Das reicht. Hinzu kommt dann
auch noch der App Store mit haufenweise
kostenloser Software.
Ach und ganz nebenbei bemerkt, Updates
über das Update Center können nicht nur
manuell im Gegensatz zu Windows gemacht werden,
sondern auch super unkompliziert, ohne Zwang.
Und ganz ehrlich, dieses Betriebssystem sieht in der Standard...
Ohne Zwang, ist richtig.
Man kann sie aber trotzdem machen und in der Regel geht auch nichts kaputt.
Selbst Artstilux, ich verwende seit Ewigkeiten, ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern, wirklich ewig Artstilux.
Und mir ist einmal, mir ist, mir ist, mir ist zweimal was kaputt gegangen.
Zweimal ist mir was kaputt gegangen.
Einmal letztens erst, da hatten die doch irgendwelche Library-Probleme bei CacheOS.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das war. Das ist erst ein paar Wochen her.
Da ist es mir einmal kaputt gegangen.
Und Archilux ist mir auch nochmal kaputt gegangen.
Da hatten sie irgendwelche Bootloader-Probleme.
Beides ließ sich aber beheben.
Also in all den Jahren ist mir das Ganze zweimal kaputt gegangen.
und ich benutze Arch Linux, was quasi das eines der, wenn du es so willst,
unstabelsten Distributionen ist.
Ansonsten, der Linux geht bei Updates nicht kaputt.
... Variante, nicht nur super modern aus,
sondern lässt sich einfach viel geiler individualisieren und anpassen.
Das stimmt.
Ohne, dass das mit tausenden von Prozessen auf den Arbeitsspeicher geht.
Und ich glaube...
Das stimmt. KDE ist echt nice, muss man mal sagen.
Ich bin mittlerweile auch richtig KDE-Fan geworden, weil es einfach funktioniert.
Du hast die Möglichkeit, 30 Milliarden Sachen zu customizen, wenn du willst.
Minus D installiert sich seine GUI. Ja, keine Ahnung, was der da treibt.
Ich habe den Eindruck, das macht er für besseren Video, für mehr Videocontent.
Aber KDE ist nice. KDE kommt eigentlich nicht in die Quere.
aber wenn man KDE konfigurieren will, kann man es konfigurieren.
Und zwar richtig.
Also es gibt kaum eine Software, die so krass konfigurieren wie KDE und KDE Software.
KDE ist richtig nice.
Und im Ernst, also der Vergleich zu GNOME,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wer freiwillig GNOME verwendet.
Ich kann es nicht verstehen.
Das ist die größte unusable Schrottsoftware,
die ich mir vorstellen kann, was Desktop-Sachen angeht.
Ich kann das nicht ab. Ich weiß, es gibt Leute,
die feiern das voll ab, aber ich krieg
Anfälle, wenn ich Gnome verwenden muss.
Und ich verstehe auch nicht,
wie es einem gefallen kann.
Die entfernen auch die Features, ja.
Übrigens, es gibt ja auch
keinen Maximieren-Knopf und sowas.
Kein Schließen, Maximieren
und Minimieren-Knopf und solche Dinger.
Und da musst du dir für jeden Scheiß
musst du dir Gnome-Tweaks installieren.
Ich verstehe nicht,
Warum man Gnome verwendet? Absolut keine Ahnung.
Diese Sache mit dem Arbeitsspeicher ist der wichtigste Punkt.
Denn nach etlichem Ausprobieren ist mir eine Sache klar geworden.
Ich persönlich werde auf privater Ebene dieses Jahr...
Die Fall Gnome ist zumindest schöner als die Fall KDE.
Okay, ja, das ist bestimmt Geschmackssache, aber...
Ja, das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, ja.
Pimp my Gnome.
Eine Stunde zwölf.
Ja.
Vielleicht ein wenig zu lang.
Ich habe schon lange kein Out of the Box KDE mehr installiert.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich KDE installiert habe, war CacheOS und das kommt ganz brauchbar vorkonfiguriert daher.
Dann habe ich Custom Shortcuts und Workspaces und Gedöns gemacht hier, ne, dass man auch ein bisschen umschalten kann und Fenster minimieren und maximieren kann mit Tastatur.
Aber ansonsten ist das top.
Ich finde Gnome noch nicht mal schick.
Was mir bei Gnome auch mega auf den Sack geht ist, wenn du bei Gnome das Startmenü drückst oder besser gesagt den Launcher, den Launcher muss man ja sagen, das Ding benutze ich ja auch nicht, den Launcher, dann zoomt das so abartig raus und sowas standardmäßig.
Da wird es mir immer schlecht bei.
Das macht quasi jeder so.
Was diesen Kanal betrifft, muss ich aber weiterhin mit Windows arbeiten.
und Benchmarks machen. Einfach aus dem Grund,
weil ich weiß, dass viele von euch Windows
benutzen und dann natürlich auch
Windows Benchmarks wollen.
Und die muss ich dann natürlich... Also ich kann ihm
vom Setup nur empfehlen, er hat ja hier
auch quasi
nicht irgendwie beschränkt an Hardware oder so.
Der hat ja massig Hardware bei sich daheim.
Der soll es einfach auch so machen.
Eine Windows-Kiste und auf der alles machen,
wo sich Windows besser für eignet.
Eine Linux-Kiste, auf der alles machen,
wo sich
wo sich Linux am besten
für eignet.
Beste aus beiden Welten. Und wie er das dann
macht,
ob er einfach zwei Monitore nimmt,
einen Monitor und dabei umschaltet,
über Capture Card
das Ganze macht, wie auch immer.
Man kann ja auch theoretisch
über Moonlight sein, Desktop Stream.
Wobei das auch ein paar Probleme hat. Das habe ich auch mal probiert.
Das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Gibt es ja viele Varianten.
Und du hast trotzdem zwei vollwertige Systeme,
wo du die jeweiligen Vorteile, oder Vorteile würde ich jetzt bei Windows nicht sagen,
die jeweiligen, ja,
an dem du so Vorteile ausspielen kannst.
Wie viele Monitore hast du? Zwei.
Stärken, ich würde es auch nicht Stärken nennen.
Also die Dinger, die man halt noch unter Windows besser machen kann als unter Linux,
die kann man dann unter Windows machen.
So ist glaube ich am besten ausgedrückt.
Ich habe zwei Monitore.
ich habe den hier
AVM
Switch wäre
vielleicht auch was, ja
also
wie gesagt, ich habe zwei Monitore, da habe ich hier
den ganzen Krempel drauf, hier die Windows-Kiste
und dann habe ich einen zweiten Monitor
der ist hier, hier so, links
neben dem Mauszeiger jetzt, den seht ihr
nicht, das ist da, wo ich
meinen Stream vorschau und Zeug drauf hab
den Chat und sowas
durch die anti cheat systeme gehen manche games nicht auf linux, ja das stimmt
und ich glaube auch, dass die, habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt
ich glaube auch, dass die Bereitschaft von Linux Usern geringer ist
sich was zu installieren, was bei der Installation
Root haben will und Kernel Module installiert
ja, also wenn du dann quasi
bei der Spieleinstallation
erstmal eine
wie hieß der Kram?
DKMS, oder?
diese
er hat die km es genau also wenn du bei der spielinstallation erstmal der dkms
können modul compilation siehst ich glaube da haben die linux leute nicht so
viel
leidensfähigkeit wie wir das user du meinst die gamer machen dass ich weiß
nicht ob die gamer das unter linux akzeptieren so ohne probleme
Außerdem bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob man mit Kernel-Modulen tatsächlich das gleiche machen kann, als mit Windows-Kernel-Level-Anti-Cheat.
Das werden da auch so eine Art Kernel-Module sein, aber da habe ich absolut keine Ahnung von, wie das funktioniert.
Vielleicht geht da auch nicht alles.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wayland wird ihn auf jeden Fall ein bisschen in die Suppe spucken.
Mit untereinander abgeschirrten Anwendungen und sowas.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber trotzdem glaube ich, dass Linux-User das...
Also, ich kann nur sagen, ich würde mich sehr wundern,
wenn ich bei einer Spieleinstallation erstmal root werden muss und auf einmal irgendwelche DKMS-Compilations anlaufen.
Was sind meine Recommendations? Was ich YouTube da so denkt?
Der Paket-Mafia ausgeliefert. Wie SAP-Unternehmer Paketboten ausbeuten.
Ja gut, das würde ich auch so unterschreiben, dass das so ist.
ich krieg
es krieg ja oft was von Amazon
aber ich glaube ich habe noch nie, Chad wie ist es
bei euch?
wie ist das bei euch? bei mir ist es so
ich krieg viele Pakete von Amazon, aber es ist
nie, nie der gleiche
Fahrer, jedes Mal wer anders
und das liegt glaube ich daran
dass die eine sehr hohe Fluktuation
haben und halt so eine automatische
Routenplanung, es ist nie der gleiche
Fahrer
bei Hermes, bei DPD
bei GLS
bei DHL,
da sind es meistens
bei der Post so ungefähr
die gleichen Leute, aber bei Amazon
nie.
Und bei Amazon ist es ja auch nicht die Leute direkt
von Amazon, das sind ja Subunternehmer
der Sub-Subunternehmer, die das machen.
Das will ich aber gerade noch mal fertig gucken, das Video.
Auch liefern. Ich glaube, dass das
Betriebssystem auch ein Punkt ist, an der die Community sich mehr oder weniger spaltet. Es gibt
eben diese voll überzeugten Linux-Nutzer und es gibt die voll überzeugten Windows-Nutzer. Leute,
Chat, Chat. Diese voll überzeugten Linux-Nutzer. Please allow me to interject for a moment.
Wer hat den Fehler gehört?
Ist jetzt nicht ernst gemeint, ne?
Genau!
Knu slash Linux
Oder Knu plus Linux
Hatten wir nicht sogar...
Moment, Moment, wir hatten doch sogar ein Emote dafür
Genau
Passend
Und es gibt die voll überzeugten Windows-Nutzer.
Und egal, was oder wer ihr seid, mir ist auch wichtig zu sagen,
dass diese Videos keinen bekehren sollen, sondern sie sollen Horizonte erweitern.
Ja, das finde ich immer gut.
Oder ich finde es gut, dass er es sagt.
Ich finde es aber blöd, dass man es überhaupt sagen muss,
weil die Leute, die springen immer so krass darauf an.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist fast noch schlimmer als damals Xbox 360 vs. PS3, wo die einen dann immer ankamen, alter scheiß Wixbox und die anderen kamen, ey, Gaystation 3, wo dann geflammt wurde, was besser ist, PSN oder Xbox Live.
Aber dazu muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, seriously, seriously, wer ernsthaft behauptet hatte zur damaligen Zeit, PSN wäre zu der Zeit besser gewesen als Xbox Live, den konnte ich nicht ernst nehmen.
Ich habe das heute hoffentlich gemacht mit Nubara OS.
Aber kleiner Tipp am Rande, das war früher schon so, bei alten Laptops hat man empfohlen, so ein Linux wie Ubuntu zu installieren,
weil man damit noch was anfangen konnte und es deutlich ressourcensparender war als Windows.
Heute gibt es eine riesen Community, die Gaming auf Linux täglich besser macht.
Und wenn man das sogar mit 16 GB Arbeitsspeicher hinbekommt, ist das eine absolut geile Sache.
Schreibt mir gerne mal in die Kommentare, ob es noch Distros gibt, die ich mir ansehen soll.
Und übrigens, für Leute, die sagen, sie suchen wirklich was ganz Sinn...
Ja, ich würde gerne von ihm eine Gentoo-Installation sehen.
Ihr auch, Chat?
So eine Runde
Gentoo installieren wäre doch mal was für...
Wenn man den Leuten dann die Lust auf Linux
verderben will, macht man sowas. Oh ja!
Oh ja! Chat, Chat, Chat! Jetzt wo ich's grad
gesehen hab, das muss jetzt sein.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Jawoll.
Econa.
Almost Heaven.
Older Twitch Chat.
All these emotes.
Wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older.
Everyone's moved on.
But I remember Twitch Chat.
Twitch Emotes
Typing Dan's Game, Forehead Swift Rage, PJ Salt and Fail Fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time.
TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitchy Molds, long ago, made you feel, you're not alone.
Kappa PogChamp, people forehead, Bible Thumb.
Twitchy Molds, still here is barren in the morning hour.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Pog is PogChamp.
Cap is CapBug.
Bible Thumb.
Twitchy Moogs.
Perfect Hands.
Bible Thumb.
Twitchy Moogs.
So.
Okay, das muss jetzt sein.
Was gibt's heute zu futtern?
Ich hab Spargel, grüne Spargel gefuttert
mit Kartoffeln dabei.
Das lädt noch nicht mal.
Das ist...
Alter!
Das hab ich da seit
seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen, Alter!
Die Hobbits, die Hobbits, die Hobbits, die Hobbits.
Tell me where is Gandalf?
Warum weiß ich das noch?
A Balrog of Morgoth.
Na gut.
Wie dem auch sei.
Ich finde das schlimm.
Ich habe das vor 15 Jahren oder so das letzte Mal gesehen.
Dass ich den ganzen Mist sogar noch weiß.
Oh Mann
Wie auch immer YouTube jetzt auf die Idee gekommen ist
Hier
So
Äh, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier
War noch irgendwas Spannendes
Genau, der wollte mir doch erzählen, warum ich
Ne Apple TV brauche, da bin ich mal gespannt
Warum brauche ich ein Apple TV
Ich habe bis jetzt noch nichts gefunden, warum ich ein Apple TV brauche
15 Jahre ist einfach 2011
Herr der Ringe war 2002
oder so die Filme
2001, 2002, 2003
Können wir das Malfoys Video sehen?
Welches denn?
Was denn?
Was hat er denn für ein...
Für ein Video, das da?
Ja gut, es geht 40 Minuten.
40 Minuten kann ich das...
Auch wenn ich die Videos gerne gucke, wir haben ja auch schon ein paar...
Aber 40 Minuten ist mir jetzt zu lang.
Ich hab ein Shield TV, ja.
Aber mal gucken, vielleicht kann er mir Apple TV
schmackhaft machen, ich glaub's ja nicht.
Hast du ein Jellyfin Black Setup?
Nö.
Ich hab ein Amazon Prime.
Basic, oder wie auch immer das heißt,
Abo, also
nicht mit,
nicht dieses
ohne Werbung,
also ich hab mal Amazon Prime Abo,
ich hab
YouTube Premium, und ich hab
ab und zu mal
ein
Netflix Abo, und ich hatte auch schon mal
ein Apple-Abo, als es
was gab, was ich gucken will. Aber ich mach
das immer so, ich erneuere das
und nachdem ich es erneuert hab, cancel
ich es gleich, dass es wirklich nur für einen Monat
läuft.
Und damit komm ich eigentlich ganz gut
hin. Gibt's die ganzen Apps,
gibt's bei mir auf dem Shield TV.
Ich hab da die ganzen üblichen Apps
drauf, ich hab die ARD und ZDF Mediathek
drauf, ich hab Joint drauf, ich hab Netflix
drauf. Ich hatte mal, ich hatte
mal Magenta TV drauf.
aber die Telekom wollte mein Geld nicht.
Die Telekom wollte mein Geld nicht.
Jetzt ist es wirklich komplett lächerlich.
Ich habe mich registriert bei der Telekom,
bei Magenta TV habe ich mich registriert,
weil es da, also,
ich habe mich registriert, weil meine Mutter da Sachen
gucken wollte, oder Sachen gucken wollte,
die es bei Magenta TV gab.
Habe ich mich bei Magenta TV registriert
und
die haben
immer irgendwas gefunden warum eine registrierung dann doch nicht erfolgreich war ja zuerst haben
sie sich beschwert über meinen namen der irgendwie nicht nicht echt klingt oder so danach haben sie
sich beschwert über meine telefonnummer die nicht echt klingt und ich hab ich hab das fünf mal
versucht und jedes Mal haben sie gesagt,
ah, hier stimmt irgendwas nicht mit
ihrer Registrierung.
Obwohl ich wohl gemerkt, ich habe jedes Mal
ordentlich mit Paypal bezahlt.
Aber das haben die ja zum Glück, also das
ging da nicht durch und ich habe
da kein Geld verloren.
Und ich habe es fünfmal
versucht, mich da zu registrieren
und es
ging nicht. Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
wisst ihr was, scheiß auf Magenta
TV,
dann
muss sie sich halt mit den ollen Sachen
begnügen, die es bei Amazon gibt.
Ja, und ich gebe zu, ich habe mich
nicht registriert mit meinem echten Namen
und meiner echten Telefonnummer,
aber Netflix ist das auch scheißegal.
Bei Netflix heiße ich auch
keine Ahnung, Peter
Wobblors oder so.
Und habe Telefonnummer 0123
454789. Das ging
Netflix komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Netflix macht sogar eine Schufa?
Was?
Das können die bei mir gerne machen.
Mich gibt es nicht bei Netflix.
Also den, den ich da hinterlegt habe.
Gibt es nicht.
Vielleicht machen die das,
wenn du, wenn es irgendwie verdächtig ist
oder so von verdächtigen IPs oder keine Ahnung.
Also die können bei mir gerne Schufa-Abfrage machen,
aber wenn sie feststellen, den gibt es halt nicht.
Also Netflix war da scheißegal
Wie ich heiße
Und in den meisten anderen Services ist es auch egal
Bei Amazon habe ich tatsächlich
Meinen echten Namen und echte Anschrift stehen
Weil ich
Bestelle halt manchmal was
Aber ansonsten
Ansonsten mache ich alles so weit möglich
mit Fake-Mails, Fake-Namen, Fake-Telefonnummern,
weil es geht dir ja allen nichts an.
Weil ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Datenschutz, schön und gut.
Es gibt so viele Leaks, du kannst eh keinem da wirklich trauen.
Aber das Beste ist, seine Daten erst gar nicht rauszugeben,
dann müssen sie auch nicht groß geschützt werden.
Oder du musst dich auch nicht darauf verlassen,
dass sie sich ordentlich schützen.
Deswegen sehe ich ja auch vieles so kritisch,
was da in letzter Zeit läuft mit irgendwelchen zentralen Registern
für XY, europäische Altersverifizierung.
und hast sie nicht gesehen, sobald du Daten hast, sind sie halt da.
Wenn du sie nicht hast, gibt es halt auch nichts, was du schützen musst.
Oder du musst dich nicht darauf verlassen, dass jemand anderes ordentlich macht.
Und ich habe eh prinzipiell wenig Vertrauen in andere Leute, dass sie da sowas...
Ich sehe es ja schon an mir, wie viel ich oftmals, was Technik angeht, verkacke,
weil ich nicht richtig nachdenke oder was zu schnell mache oder nicht richtig durchdacht habe oder sowas.
und ich gebe anderen noch viel mehr davon aus,
dass sie noch mehr verkacken.
Und deswegen will ich gar nicht, dass sie so viel von mir wissen.
Äh, Pay...
PayPal...
PayPal habe ich, glaube ich, auch echte Namen.
Ja, ja, PayPal habe ich auch echte Namen.
Da habe ich kein Fake.
Gedöns.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ob mein Streaming-Anbieter jetzt weiß,
wie ich heiße und wo ich wohne,
ist doch scheißegal, ey.
Das geht die auch überhaupt nichts an, das brauchen
die überhaupt nicht.
PayPal verstehe ich, das ist eine Bank,
die müssen gewisse Auflagen erfüllen, Amazon
logischerweise muss was geliefert kriegen, ja.
Aber der Streaming-Service,
solange der sein Geld kriegt,
dem hat's mal gefälligst komplett
sonst wo am Bobbes vorbeizugehen,
wie ich heiße, wo ich wohne,
was ich für eine Telefonnummer habe.
Was ich für eine E-Mail-Adresse habe.
Das braucht überhaupt nicht sich zu interessieren.
Also ich benutze PayPal immer noch gerne.
PayPal und den Rest mache ich auch hauptsächlich über Apple Pay.
In Apple Pay habe ich eine Kreditkarte
und die Karte von der Bank hinterlegt.
Weil manche Läden haben Probleme mit einer und nehmen dafür die andere und umgedreht.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Warum sollte ich mir eine Apple TV kaufen?
Wir haben 2026, also warum bitte braucht man noch so ein Ding?
Mein Fernseher kann quasi jeden Bildstandard abspielen.
Kommt mit soliden Ladezeiten, bietet Zugang zu so gut wie allen...
Ich bin... Ich hab ja auch einen Fernseher mit Android TV drauf.
Ich meine nicht mein Shield TV.
Mein Fernseher hat ein Android TV drauf.
das benutze ich nicht, gar nicht
null, das außerdem ist das
laggy as fuck
und du bist darauf angewiesen, dass sie dann auch
die Sachen freigeben und so, kannst du
komplett knicken
ich benutze das nicht
das einzige Mal
wo ich jemals in dem
Fernseh-Android-TV was gemacht hab
war glaube ich beim Einstellen, was
der Default
ähm
Default-Input ist, dass der immer
automatisch umschaltet
Aber ansonsten, nie benutzt.
Dafür habe ich mein Shield TV dran.
Das ist so weich und flüssig.
Es wäre mega geil, wenn es mal ein neues Shield TV gäbe.
Das aktuelle Shield TV
ist glaube ich von 2019 oder so.
Das ist richtig alt.
Da ist ja im Shield TV
ähnliche Hardware drin
wie in der Switch 1.
Achso, mit dem Internet verbunden
habe ich meinen Fernseher auch nicht.
Ja, ich verwende den, obwohl er ein Android-TV hat, verwende ich den als ganz dummen Fernseher.
Und alles andere mache ich über mein Shield-TV oder halt über diesen DVB-C-Tuner-Box.
Mit 8-fach-Tuner und einem Linux drauf.
Die Apps und die Bildqualität ist überragend. Das Teil hat 3000 Euro gekostet.
Und was ich richtig feier ist, was ich auch so seit Jahren hab, ich hab so ein nachrüstbares Ambilight hier hinten am Fernseher dran. Das sind so LED-Leisten. Und dann so ein Zwischenstecker zwischen HDMI von dem Output und HDMI vom Fernseher. Das ist richtig geil, weil ich hab auch ein bisschen wie er hier, ich hab halt eine große weiße Wand um den Fernseher drum. Da hängt nichts dran an der Seite.
und durch das Ambilight
wirkt das einfach viel
das kann man schlecht beschreiben
der Übergang
zwischen Fernsehbildschirm und Wand
wirkt halt so in den Augenwinkeln
viel weicher und dadurch
wirkt das viel, viel größer
und
wie sagen sie bei den Games immer
mehr immersive
finde ich, das ist mega geil
dieses Ding, das ist so, das habe ich glaube ich schon ein paar Mal
gezeigt, das gibt es leider nicht mehr
ähm, Dream Screen
Pro oder so
oder hieß das, hieß das mal
das gibt's nicht mehr
das haben die
ja, Dream Screen hier
das haben die leider eingestellt
weil ich glaube, ich nicht so gut verkauft hat
ja, aber das ist schon echt nice
ja, guck
ja, das
ich meine, das haben die maximal blöd aufgenommen.
Wenn du eine spiegelnde Wand dahinter hast,
dann siehst du die LEDs und so.
Aber guck,
hier siehst du es halt auch gut.
Es ist richtig, richtig,
richtig cool.
Also damals hatte das,
ich glaube, damals hatte das nur Philips,
die hatten das noch sogar, diese Ambilight-Geschichte
irgendwie auch patentiert.
Und ich bin da echt
zufrieden mit. Also wenn ich mir mal einen neuen Fernseher kaufe,
dann einen, entweder der sowas
drin hat, der mir aber auch ansonsten gefällt.
Oder ich kaufe mir nochmal sowas.
Gibt es ja so Nachrüstdinger.
...erklären, dass diese Kiste noch
einen Mehrwert bietet? Ganz lange wollte ich
mir das nicht eingestehen. Mittlerweile weiß ich
aber, ein Apple TV kann man nicht nur gebrauchen,
wenn man einen alten Fernseher mit Steinzeit-Software
hat, sondern vor allem, wenn man
einen schweineteuren neuen Smart TV besitzt.
Der Apple TV 4K wurde zuletzt
2022 geupdatet und somit steht
eigentlich der Nachfolger schon in den Startlöchern.
Aktuelle Gerüchte lassen wir mal verlauten,
dass der wohl erst mit Siri 2.0 kommt,
Und die braucht wohl noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Ich behaupte aber, es lohnt sich selbst jetzt noch zu zu sagen.
Das heißt, da haben sie die ganze KI-Geschichte dann outsourced zu Google oder Anthropic oder sowas.
Weil Apple ist ja da ziemlich hinten dran.
Was irgendwie witzig ist, ne?
Apple ist im AI-Game ziemlich hinten dran, aber hat sehr gute Hardware für KI.
Eigentlich irgendwie widersprüchlich, oder?
...monat ein neues Modell auf den Markt kommt,
ihr könnt noch von dem aktuellen Apple TV profitieren.
Apropos Gerüchte.
Ich habe gehört, OwnGalaxy bringt jetzt eigenen Merch auf den Markt.
Ich muss euch nicht enttäuschen.
Erst mal eine Runde Sellout.
Trotzdem könnt ihr heute diese zwei OwnGalaxy-Tassen gewinnen.
Jeder Kommentar nimmt teil.
Alle Infos zum Gewinnspiel findet ihr in der Infobox.
Genauso wie alles Wichtige zu dem Gerät,
mit dem wir diese Tassen bedruckt haben.
Das hat nämlich mit dem neuen UV-Drucker E1 funktioniert
von Eufemake, dem Sponsor des heutigen Videos.
Okay, Sellout.
Ich geb das, ich geb das mal.
Oh, das ist, das ist aber schick.
Okay, das ist schon irgendwie ganz cool.
Ich brauch es null.
Aber das ist schon irgendwie ganz, ganz nice, ja.
selbst. Der Preis für die verwendete Tinte ist
nämlich für einfache Drucke sehr gering.
Die lässt sich im Übrigen ganz einfach tauschen und trocknet in
Sekundenschnelle durch UV-Licht. Ihr könnt schwierige
Formen wie Rundungen mit dem E1 im Hand umdrehen,
mit eigenen Logos, Sprüchen oder Bildern.
Irgendwie ist das Ding cool.
Ich werde es mir nicht kaufen,
weil ich davon
Abstand nehmen muss, mir sinnloses Zeug
zu kaufen.
Aber
es finde ich cool.
Ich wurde
influenced, ja. Und wenn ich mir das hier mal so anschaue,
oh, ein Galaxy-Merch, wär irgendwie schon
nice, oder? Oder hier, wie wär's mit so einem
Paddy-Untersetzer? Damit seid ihr lowkey auf einem
ganz anderen Level unterwegs, also
Ich cringe immer bei der Gen-Alpha-Sprache, Alter.
Vielleicht sollte ich doch nochmal
über ein ganz eigenes Spinnesses nachdenken.
Darf er so? Okay, fangen wir mal
damit an, was ihr seht, wenn ihr euren Fernseher
einschaltet. Und bei dem Modell hier
ist es wirklich eine ganze Menge. Ich mein, kleine Kacheln.
Mittelre Kachel, große Kachel, eine riesige Kachel, irgendwelche Einstellungen an der Seite.
Und von dem, was man sieht, wenn man hier weiter runter scrollt, will ich gar nicht erst anfangen.
Was soll das? Das ist ja ganz weit weg von irgendwelchen personalisierten Vorschlägen.
Und das ist grundsätzlich ein Problem bei Smart TVs, dass sie mittlerweile echt wirklich oft vollgeklatscht wird mit Werbung.
Also wie gesagt, nicht nur ältere, sondern auch moderne High-End-Fernseher profitieren durchaus von einem Apple TV.
Mit einem Apple TV erwartet euch hingegen das hier.
Nicht nur eine werbefreie Ohrabdeckung.
Ein cleaner Look oder sowas kommt jetzt gleich.
Sondern auch eine derart aufgeräumte, wie ihr es euch nicht ausdenken könnt.
Ein ganz cleanes Kachelsystem.
Ja, wusste ich doch, wusste ich das.
Die Apple-Leute stehen immer so drauf zu sagen, dass das so clean ist.
Eben ohne irgendwelche Abzweigungen und wechselnde Layouts und Größen.
Das Ding lässt sich im Übrigen auch ganz einfach bedienen.
Ähnlich wie es vom iPhone oder iPad kennt.
Geöffnete Apps lassen sich auffächern, mit einem Daumenwisch nach oben schließen.
Man kann Kacheln verschieben, Ordner erstellen und sich ganz leicht mit Peripherie verbinden.
Dazu gleich mehr.
Das macht ihr im Übrigen alles mit dieser Fernbedienung.
Die gegenüber einer klassischen Fernbedienung absolut King ist.
Aus einem einzigen Stück Aluminium gefräst, liegt diese Fernbedienung wirklich super nice in der Hand.
Ich war, wo wir gerade beim Thema Fernbedienung sind, da muss ich mal was sagen.
Ich war echt skeptisch bei der Shield TV.
Bei der neuen Shield TV, also neu.
bei der aktuellen
Shield TV Remote.
Die ist nämlich dreieckig.
Meine alte,
meine alte, die hier,
die ist kaputt.
Die ging nicht mehr.
Dann habe ich mir die neue Shield TV Remote
gekauft und die ist dreieckig.
Da war ich erstmal, ja,
da war ich erstmal sehr skeptisch,
ob das was taugt.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
finde ich das eigentlich ganz nice.
Du hast es gleich
viel besser in der Hand.
Du musst es nicht erst noch so selbst ein bisschen drehen
in der Hand.
Und die Beleuchtung der Tasten ist auch
nice.
War noch genau die richtige Geschwindigkeit.
Ich fand die am Anfang richtig
ja, ich bin gedacht, ah, ob mir das
gefällt. Mittlerweile muss ich sagen, echt ganz gut.
Und bietet zudem eine clevere Touch.
Ja, wie ich darauf komme. Die hier,
finde ich, erinnert mich von der Optik ein bisschen an die
erste Shield TV Remote. Natürlich
doppelt so teuer und
Apple-mäßig, ja. Fühlt sich bestimmt
auch nicht so billig an. Bei dem Ding hier
fehlt ja zum Beispiel schon mal die Stummschalten-Taste.
Also im Ernst, lautlos macht ihr den Fernseher,
indem ihr die Leiser-Taste, diese Wippe hier,
nach unten gedrückt haltet.
Warum? Aber, und das muss man
sagen, die Bildqualität meines Fernsehers
ist wirklich hervorragend. Und viele neue
Fernseher haben wirklich ein tolles Bild.
Das Problem ist nur, dass unterschiedliche
Inhalte mit 24, 30
oder 50 FPS oft nicht richtig
verarbeitet werden können, weil moderne Fernseher eben konstant 60 Hertz ausgeben in Bezug auf
spezielle Apps. Das liegt nicht an den Streaming-Apps, weil die geben schon die richtigen Informationen
raus, sondern am Fernseher selbst. Euer TV-Betriebssystem will, dass alles flüssig und stabil läuft.
Und bevor es hier zu kurzen Ladezeiten oder schwarzen Bildern kommt, werden Apps wie die von Netflix
beispielsweise einfach standardmäßig in 60 Hertz angezeigt. An die sich der Fernseher tatsächlich
auch anpassen kann, aber dem Originalfootage, also dem Film, entspricht das natürlich trotzdem nicht.
Ein Beispiel dafür ist das sogenannte Jada-Problem. Damit wirkt eine Kamerafahrt plötzlich nicht mehr sauber, sondern leicht ruckelig.
Obwohl das Ausgangsmaterial eigentlich komplett flüssig wäre. Vielleicht kennt ihr das.
Das sind so Probleme, die hast du tatsächlich bei analogen Film- und Röhrenfernsehen nicht.
Der Apple TV geht aber diesen Schritt, den der Fernseher oft nicht macht und gibt direkt über das HDMI-Kabel dann beispielsweise 24 FPS aus.
Er zwingt den Fernseher quasi über die Funktion an Bildrate anpassen, exakt auf 24 Hertz oder 25, 30 und so weiter umzuschalten.
Das Ergebnis ist eine native, ruckelfreie Bewegung, wie sie vom Regisseur auch gedacht war.
Diese automatisierten Bildeinstellungen klappen dank an Dynamikbereich anpassen, auch in Bezug auf SDR und HDR-Inhalte.
Das sind ja im Prinzip hinterlegte...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Shield-TV sowas kann.
...Standards, die Helligkeit, Farbe und Kontraste beeinflussen.
Moderne Fernseher haben ja auch einen HDR-Modus.
Der SDR-Videomaterial aber nicht selten auch einfach nur in HDR hochrechnet.
Was allerdings oft gar nicht besser aussieht und mehr Strom verbraucht.
Auch hier verhält sich der Apple TV ähnlich wie bei der Bildrate.
Er wählt, wenn gewünscht, stets das richtige Bildprofil aus und passt es damit an das jeweilige Footage an.
Also SDR-Inhalte bleiben dann in SDR-Qualität.
Ja, so sollte es eigentlich auch sein.
Und werden nicht künstlich hochgerechnet und HDR-Inhalte werden dann auch in HDR gezeigt.
Das bleibt alles so, wie es hier ist. Und es wird hier nichts dran rütteln.
Gleiches gilt für Dolby Vision zum Beispiel.
Das könnt ihr dann immer in der oberen rechten Ecke ablesen.
Falls ihr euch übrigens wundert, weshalb wir nicht über die Farbanpassung per TrueDepth-Kamera eures iPhones sprechen,
dieses Apple TV Feature halten wir für ein bisschen überschätzt und einige Tests haben...
Was für ein Ding? Was macht das Teil?
Kamera eures iPhones sprechen, dieses Apple TV Feature halten wir für ein bisschen...
Der kann... Versuchen die da so eine Art Kalibrierung oder was?
... ein bisschen überschätzt und einige Tests haben sogar gezeigt, dass die Farbeinstellungen,
vor allem bei LCD-Bildschirmen die Qualität eher verschlechtern.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich weiß ja nicht.
Über diese Funktion hinaus bietet der Apple TV aber auch noch weitere Möglichkeiten,
die nicht unterschätzt werden dürfen.
Neben dem Nutzen von Apples eigenen Abo-Diensten natürlich, wie zum Beispiel Fitness Plus,
ist auch Apple eigene Hardware clever integriert.
Wer beispielsweise zu später Stunde niemanden mehr stören möchte und trotzdem den Film gucken will,
der kann ganz easy seine AirPods öffnen.
Die Software erkennt die dann ganz von allein und man kann sie einfach hier oben in der Ecke auswählen.
Ähnlich einfach funktioniert das im Übrigen auch mit vielen Controllern.
Mit denen ihr dann zum Beispiel eine Vielzahl von Apple Arcade Games zocken könnt.
Man muss aber sagen, hier merkt man, dass der Prozessor mittlerweile ein bisschen hinterher hängt.
Viele Spiele laufen einfach nicht mehr richtig flüssig.
Und man merkt an dieser Stelle auch, dass der Apple...
Na gut, dafür bräuchte ich kein Apple TV.
...TV nicht die volle Aufmerksamkeit von Apple bekommt.
So ein Xbox Wireless Controller zum Beispiel funktioniert problemlos.
Der neue Switch 2 Pro Controller aber nicht.
Der der ersten Generation aber schon.
Und das Ding ist mittlerweile auch irgendwie schon ein Jahr alt oder so, ne?
Also, verstehe ich nicht.
Ich mag die Apple in ihr Form.
Sei es jetzt bei AirPods oder auch bei den mitgelieferten.
Ich mag diese Form überhaupt nicht.
Der ist ganz schön klein, oder?
Wenn man sich das mal so anguckt.
Könnte auch ein Raspberry Pi in einem extra Gehäuse drin sein.
Ist nicht.
Klar.
Aber von der Größe her.
Kann der auch ZigBee?
Also viele Threads.
Sachen gibt es jetzt ja noch gar nicht.
Und haben auch nicht viele Leute.
Ist Meta nicht ein aufgebohrter ZigBee?
Meta ist oben drüber.
Also du kannst Meta Transport über Thread oder über ZigBee machen.
Und ich glaube, Zigbee ist da aktuell noch deutlich verbreiteter als Thread.
Und ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Bauchgefühl, das bleibt auch so.
... auch Airplay-Signale, also den Ton darüber ausgeben.
Bedeutet diese Boxen hier zum Beispiel...
Ja, Seawave war eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich habe hier auch noch ein paar Seawave-Fenster- und Türsensoren.
Das hat sich schon die letzten Jahre über ziemlich so an, immer weiter an letzte Positionen geschoben.
Die kann man ohne Apple TV nicht mit dem Fernseher verbinden.
Oder an die hintere Position geschoben.
Habt ihr einen, ist das dann kein Problem mehr.
Ein echter Game Changer für mich ist die Suchfunktion für die Apple TV Fernbedienung.
Diese Fernbedienung lässt sich nämlich genau wie ein AirTag aufspüren.
Je näher man kommt, desto stärker vibriert das iPhone.
Wieso kann das nicht jede Fernbedienung?
Naja, aber wo Licht ist, da ist auch Schatten.
Das merkt man beispielsweise am App Store, der nicht so wirklich up-to-date scheint.
Darin finden sich Apps, die einfach tot sind.
Airbnb beispielsweise verweist in der Apple TV App schlichtweg auf die iPhone und iPad.
Au, das ist ja auch toll.
Ich muss sagen, ich hätte es echt gefeiert.
Vor allem dieser Text.
Please.
Airbnb beispielsweise verweist in der Apple TV App schlichtweg auf die iPhone und iPad.
Please enjoy.
iPad App.
Erstmal sagen, gibt es nicht, aber dann please enjoy das mal auf dem iPhone.
Wenn ich Airbnb auf dem Apple TV hätte nutzen können. Haufenweise Apps laufen aber auch einfach gar nicht rund.
Und die App Charts lassen eher vermuten, dass es sich um einen zwielichtigen Android Play Store von irgendeinem asiatischen Nischenverband handelt.
Also was geht ab bitte?
Aber das ist tatsächlich beim Android TV App Store auch so ein bisschen...
Deswegen ist das coole bei Android TV, dass man immer noch Apps sideloaden kann, bis Google das dann irgendwann abschaltet.
Was Streaming Apps angeht, wie Netflix, Disney Plus und so weiter, das läuft alles wirklich super flüssig.
Aber auch FaceTime für den Fernseher klappt seit einiger Zeit ja in der Theorie.
Die Realität sieht aber so aus, dass Calls oft das Gerät überlasten, einfrieren oder einfach alles abstürzt.
Und da spürt man dann schon, dass ein Nachfolger eine gute Idee wäre.
Also es gibt noch eine ganze Menge Potenzial, dass das Apple TV nicht ausnutzt.
Aber ihr habt trotzdem gesehen, dass das auch in die Jahre gekommene Gerät modernsten Fernsehern noch etwas zu bieten hat.
Was ist eure Lieblingsfunktion? Schreibt es uns gerne in die Kommentare und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Video.
Ich habe ja logischerweise keine, weil das Video soll mir an der Apple TV erst schmackhaft machen.
Aber ich wüsste jetzt immer noch nicht genau, warum ich das brauche.
Warte, ich verrunde Windows Virus an Linux.
Gut, der wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Bis er dann an irgendwas
Komisches Windows Spezielles
Probiert, was in Wine nicht implementiert ist
Aber prinzipiell wird der dann unter Wine
Genauso funktionieren
Kann man eigentlich
Antivirus Software unter Wine laufen lassen?
Ist mir gerade so die Idee gekommen
Geht das überhaupt?
Oder wollen die da irgendwelche abgedrehten Dinger machen
Die Wine nicht unterstützt?
Ne, ne, ne
Da habe ich auf den
Hab ich jetzt auch keinen Bock drauf
Hab ich jetzt
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt
Äh
Ne
Weiß nicht
Ich glaube ich habe auch genug
Geschwätzt ich merke schon ein bisschen im Hals
Fireship hat neues Video.
Lass mich raten.
KI-Video.
Inside every operating system concept in one video.
Okay, guck mal.
Ein Nicht-KI.
Fireship-Video.
Right now you're watching this video.
Bei Fireship bin ich mir mittlerweile immer nicht sicher,
ob die Stimme noch von ihm eingesprochen ist oder mittlerweile komplett KI-isiert ist.
Hat ja mal gesagt, er will seine Stimme digitalisieren.
Letztlich ist deine CPU mit etwa 400 anderen Programmen unterwegs.
Die Chrome verwendet keine Grundlage für 20 GB RAM.
Und irgendwie läuft dein Cursor immer noch los, wenn du die Maschine wickelst.
Oder einfach.
Ähm.
Gucken wir mal.
Okay.
16 Gigabyte von 64 Gigabyte sind belegt.
Da ist noch Luft nach oben, Leute.
Hey, so.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pocket Subscription.
Ich muss mal nachgucken.
Ich glaube, ich habe die Hälfte vorhin gar nicht gesehen.
Ne.
Hab ich alles. McFly! Dich hab ich glaube ich nicht gesehen. Dankeschön.
Subscriptions.
Poggers.
Warum hast du Citrix drauf? Für Homeoffice Einwahlstells.
was in 1956 bei General Motors verliehen wurde,
weil ein Ingenieur beschlossen hat, dass die Menschheit bessere Dinge zu tun hatte,
als Hand-Feed-Punch-Karten in einem 2-Storey-IBM-Mainframe zu machen.
Es konnte genau ein Programm auf einmal runten,
hatte keine Memory-Verteidigung, keine User, keine File,
und es ist noch weniger verletzt als Windows Millennium Edition.
Es ist jetzt 70 Jahre später, und in diesem Video
wirst du endlich verstehen, wie der Bootloader, Prozesse,
Scheduling, Threads, System-Calls, Virtual Memory, Interrupts,
Privileged Rings, I.O., Index-Nodes und mehr
all work together in perfect harmony by figuring out exactly what happens in your computer from
the moment you press the power button to the moment you rage quit and shut it down.
Stage one, the bootloader.
Chance vertan, das Video vom echten Gangster einzublenden.
You press the power button, electricity hits the motherboard and the CPU wakes up in the
most primitive state possible.
At this point, there's no memory management or even a concept of files.
Ja, das Ding, beim Aufwachen oder beim Einschalten, denkt ja eine aktuelle CPU immer noch, sie ist in 8086.
Das ist jetzt ganz stark vereinfacht und schnell gewesen.
Aber gut, in elf Minuten, was willst du da auch machen?
Auf der x86 sind es vier, aber im Grunde genommen sind es nur zwei.
exploiten kann mit ganz furchtbar abenteuerlichen Dingern.
So war das ja unter Windows 98 auch.
Windows 98 ist teilweise gecrashed, wenn du das CD-Laufwerk zu langsam zugemacht hast.
Das ist kein Witz.
Dann hast du ein Blue Screen gekriegt und konntest dann auf Versuche trotzdem weiterzulaufen drücken.
Ja, es gab unter Windows 98, hast du irgendwas geklickt und dann hat irgendeine Software gesagt,
ah, legen Sie jetzt die Original-CD ein, um Sachen nachzuladen.
Und dann hast du das eingelegt und zugemacht.
Und wenn du zu langsam warst, dann kam dein Blue Screen,
oder besser gesagt, wenn dein Laufwerk zu langsam war, die CD zu laden,
kam dann ein Blue Screen und du konntest dann drücken auf, ich versuche fortzusetzen.
Das habe ich sogar auch mal in irgendeinem Video bei mir auf YouTube erzählt.
Ich glaube, wo es um Hardbleed ging.
physical address by a piece of hardware called the MMU, the Memory Management Unit, which
itself uses a data structure called a page table that the kernel is building right now.
Memory is handed out in chunks called pages, typically 4 kilobytes each, but what's really
interesting is that each process gets its own page table, and that means two applications
can work together without screwing each other over.
Like your browser can't read your password manager's memory and vice versa.
They live in parallel universes that only the kernel can see between.
Pretty cool, but the MMU also caches recent translations in a tiny structure called the TLB, the Translation Look-Aside Buffer.
A translation, meaning a virtual address mapped to a physical address.
When a program touches a page that isn't in RAM, the MMU raises a page fault, which wakes the kernel up and loads a page from disk and resumes the program like nothing happened.
And now that we have these memory lies in place, it's time for stage 4, the file system.
Your disk, at the lowest level, is a long line of numbered blocks.
Aber ein Filesystem ist das Software, das darüber sprichst und dich mit diesen schönen Files und Foldern anbietet.
Der Colonel Mount...
Variante, die auch ein TFS konnten.
Nee, gell?
Das war damals alles FAT32.
Und gab es da nicht auch Probleme,
wenn die Dateien größer als 4 GB oder sowas waren?
Aha, da war doch irgendwas.
Oder wenn die Festplatte größer als 4 GB war.
Nee.
Ah, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das war zumindest jetzt nicht so geil damals.
ZFS, beste.
Aber bei ZFS ist das alles nochmal deutlich komplizierter.
Und ich behaupte nicht, dass ich das verstehen würde, was genau bei ZFS abgeht.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich eine Handvoll Leute auf der Welt, die das wirklich verstehen.
Der hat ja immer gute Transitions von seinem Inhalt zu Sellout.
Also kannst du statt von Drowning in YAML einfach deine Repo verbinden.
ist eine asb.net anwendung das heißt du willst wahrscheinlich das und das machen
das war ich ganz nice and railway will riedger code and set up the right config
for you automatically or you can use the new railway see alive with their
official agent skills to let codex cloud ja wenn aus entdeckt der mtfs kann schon
sein dass wir das entgegen kommen ist aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es nicht
unter windows keine ahnung m oder so auch die möglichkeit gab ntfs zu benutzen
Aber vielleicht war das auch echt ein Feature, was es erst dann quasi ab Windows 2000, also Windows 2000 war ja damals versucht, die Zusammenführung von ME und Windows NT.
Vielleicht gab es das dann für die breite Nutzung erst da.
Windows 2000 war richtig pock für die damalige Zeit, ja.
Okay.
Ja, XP auf jeden Fall.
Developers, Developers, Developers, Developers.
Developers, Developers.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, so eine 30-40 Sekunden Werbeunterbrechung bei Fireship ist ordentlich teuer,
weil Fireship hat halt einen riesen Vorteil für so Werbeanbieter.
Und zwar, der hat viele Aufrufe und viele Abonnenten, viele Aufrufe, aber ein Großteil der Abonnenten interessiert sich halt auch für das, was die Leute da anbieten.
Das wird bestimmt nicht billig sein.
Erinnert sich noch einer dran?
Und by the way, es ist genau das passiert, was ich gesagt habe.
Nicht Crowdstriker.
Crowdstrike.
Es ist genau das passiert, was ich gesagt habe.
Es hat keine Sau
interessiert nach kurzer Zeit.
Die haben ja damals gesagt, oh,
das war's mit Crowdstriken. Ich habe damals
im Stream auch schon gesagt, so nach dem Wort, Leute,
das interessiert in einem Jahr oder in ein paar Monaten
keine Sau mehr.
Eigentlich, eigentlich
Hätte ich hier sogar noch kaufen müssen, ey.
in the kernel. Interrupts are the magic that
lets your computer react instantly to input.
Like when you move the mouse and
interrupt fires and the cursor moves.
Or if your Wi-Fi receives some data from the internet
and interrupt fires and the network stack
wakes up so that applications can use it.
Basically, the entire machine
is driven by tiny electrical screams
from hardware saying, hey, something happened.
Deal with it. But now that all the drivers
are loaded, we can move on to stage 6,
PID 1, the first
process. The kernel is now fully operational
Also Windows kann das zumindest probieren, den Grafiktreiber neu zu starten.
Das habe ich schon öfters mal erlebt, als ich ein bisschen zu viel übertaktet habe.
und es abgekackt ist, aber manchmal crasht es auch.
Und PID-1,
in dem Fall System D,
hat auch die Aufgabe,
gestorbene Prozesse zu collecten
und sowas, sonst hast du irgendwelche Zombie-Prozesse.
Die Kernel panikiert und das ganze System geht runter.
Aber ein wichtiges Ding hier zu verstehen ist, dass PID 1 in Ring 3 läuft, der Userspace.
Und das bedeutet, dass von diesem Moment an alles, was auf deiner Maschine läuft, die Kernel für Vermögen fragen muss.
Und das ist, wo Stage 7 kommt, System-Kollen,
die vielleicht die einzige wichtigste API in der Computing, die du je eigentlich nicht mit der Hand geschrieben hast.
Wenn ein Prozess ein File lesen möchte, kann es nicht nur in den Disk reichen.
Die CPU wird physisch verabschieden.
Anstattdessen muss es einen System-Call machen, wo es Argumente in bestimmte Register einlädt,
ein spezielles Instruktionssystem triggert und die CPU von Ring 3 zurück zu Ring 0 schaltet.
Diese Grenze ist die einzige Grund, warum dein Computer sicher ist.
Wenn du je in C programmiert bist, denkst du, du bist ein Hardcore-Low-Level-Ingenieur.
Aber wenn du eine Funktion nutzt wie Print in deinem C-Code,
kannst du nicht erkennen, dass es tatsächlich einen richtigen System-Call unter dem Hügel macht.
Auf Linux gibt es rund 400 verschiedene System-Calls,
Und das sind die eigentlichen API's deines Computers. Alles andere ist nur eine Bibliothek auf dem Topf.
Wir haben im Stream schon öfters direkte Kern-API-Calls gemacht.
Zwei der wichtigsten Systemcalls sind Fork und Exec, die in der User-Space neue Prozesse erzeugen.
Wenn du die Desktop-Bilder siehst, hast du Dutzende oder sogar Hunderten von running-Prozessen.
Und da kommt Stage 8, der Scheduler, rein.
Aber warte mal, dein Computer hat nur 8 CPU-Cores, also wie manche Prozesse gleichzeitig hunderten.
at the same time. You can think of the scheduler
like an air traffic controller at a busy
airport. All the airplanes...
Was? Was? Moment, Moment, was? Chat.
Mal eine schwere Frage, die ich auf
einem Kanal auf YouTube gehört habe, der
PCs zusammengebaut hat.
Mal wissen, wie die Frage heißt.
Ja, sag halt.
Erzähl.
Was?
Der erste RAM hatte wie viel Speicherkapazität?
Boah, der allererste RAM, die Dinger sahen ja nicht so aus, wie man das heute kennt.
Das waren ja so Drahtdinger.
Ja? Ja?
Das ist so, so, so, genau.
Das waren so Draht, ach Quatsch.
Auf gar keinen Fall 16 Kilobyte, viel, viel weniger.
Das waren so Draht,
Drahtgestelle waren das.
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Äh.
Sech, sech,
16, äh,
16,
ein, ein Byte,
sag ich, ein Byte.
Ne, ich sag 16.
Ich sag, ich, ich sag,
16 Bit. 2 Byte.
126.
126 war es.
Bits.
128.
Okay.
Ja.
Es ist auf jeden Fall wenig.
So viel war mir klar.
Also wenn einer was von Kilobyte
schreibt, du wusstest gleich,
definitiv keine kilobyte 128 bytes tatsächlich okay das ist mehr als
gedacht habe das muss ja dann ziemlich großes stück metall draht gewesen sein
michael fufft spiel jahren wollen
Moment, ich guck mir mal ein Bild von dem Ding an.
Intel 1103.
Ne, das ist nicht der erste RAM.
Das ist garantiert nicht der erste RAM.
Der erste RAM waren so Drahtgeflechtete Dinger.
Okay, dann vielleicht der erste RAM, der ein bisschen so ist, wie das, was wir heute kennen.
Draht, Wire, muss ich da Wire irgendwie suchen.
Weiß nicht, ob es da...
Schon eher...
Das ist aber nicht das, was ich meine.
Weiß jemand, was ich suchen kann?
Wie das heißt?
Diese Drahtge...
Computer Memory.
Ja.
Weiß ich aber auch nicht.
Magnetic Core Memory.
Ja.
Sowas.
So Dinger hier in der Richtung meinte ich
Hier sowas, ja genau
Hier
Wo du Drähte, wo du ganz viele Drähte hast
Das ist quasi der erste Ramm
Wenn dir das Ding auf den Fuß gefallen ist, war der platt
Die konntest du nicht zu Hause einbauen, nee.
Damals hatte auch noch keiner Computer daheim.
Es gab ja Leute, die damals gesagt haben, so diese Sachen mit Computer und so, das wird sich nicht durchsetzen.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass das, was du gepostest hast, der erste RAM ist, der von der Funktionsweise oder sowas in der Richtung ist, wie wir es heute haben.
Ja.
Wahnsinnig, 640 KB
und hat das Bill Gates
eigentlich nie gesagt?
Es wird ihm nur nachgesagt,
dass er das gesagt hätte.
... Planen oder Prozesse, und der Scheduler entscheidet, wer auf der Runway landen kann,
was in diesem Fall die CPU ist.
Die Kern-Developer haben viele verschiedene Architekturen versucht, um diese Herausforderung
zu beantworten, aber moderne Linux nutzt nun eine Technik, die heißt, erst die vormittigste
verfügbare Virtual-Termin.
Das klingt wie ein sehr einfach zu merkende und selbsterklärende Name, oder?
... Boss in Elden Ring, aber es nutzt eine Vielzahl von Regeln, um zu beachten, dass
jeder Prozess seinen rechten Teil von der CPU-Zeit bekommt.
dann wir rennen zu einer problem ist am application wollte die multiple things
at once without the over head of mutter haus das das braucht man multis wedding
wobei man nicht wirklich multis wedding braucht welcher high iq chat was weiß
von euch was der unterschied ist zwischen wie heißt das auf deutsch
Fuck, jetzt kann ich mir nicht mal die Frage richtig stellen.
Parallelisierung und...
Moment.
Ich bin selbst zu dumm.
Multi-Threading versus Multi-Processing?
Ja.
Okay.
Blödsinn.
Okay, wenn ich schon zu dumm bin, die Frage zu stellen, dann...
Lassen wir es.
Also, worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte, ist,
dass du auch auf einem Single-Core mehrere Prozesse,
ich nenne es mal parallel oder simultan ausführen kannst,
indem du einfach ganz schnell zwischen den Prozessen hin und her schaltest.
Aber wirklich parallel läuft da nichts.
Genau, die sind Concurrency vs. Parallel, genau, sowas meinte ich. Also du kannst auf einem Single-Core-CPU auch viele Prozesse spawnen, du kannst sogar theoretisch mehrere Threads aufmachen, Betriebssystems Threads, die dann halt unter der Haube von einem Scheduler CPU-Zeit bekommen.
Es wird dann einfach nur ganz schnell zwischen diesen unterschiedlichen Prozessen umgeschaltet.
Und das ging ja auch gut.
Müsst ihr euch mal überlegen.
Also sehr, sehr lange Zeit waren CPUs Single-Core.
und man hat halt massive
Taktraten
und Architektursprünge gemacht in der Zeit.
Die Dinger sind ja innerhalb von
einem Jahr quasi doppelt so schnell geworden.
Und das wirklich
jahrzehntelang.
Und da war
gar keine Notwendigkeit für,
dass man da irgendwie mehrere CPUs hat,
um Sachen wirklich parallel auszuführen.
Es hat gereicht, ja, man konnte mehrere Programme starten und das Betriebssystem hat das dann so gescheduled, dass die halt alle mehr oder weniger verteilt CPU-Zeit bekommen.
Ja, es gab eine, das stimmt, es gab eine Roadmap von Intel, laut der hätten wir 2008 oder so 10 Gigahertz CPUs haben sollen und sowas.
Und irgendwann, als das dann nicht mehr funktionierte, als man irgendwann festgestellt hat, so ungefähr auch, würde ich mal sagen, so zu Pentium 4 Zeiten, wo man dann festgestellt hat, hey, diese Geschichte mit, wir verdoppeln einfach die Taktraten, das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Man stößt hier langsam an Grenzen, was so thermisch machbar ist.
Und ein bisschen später hat man dann festgestellt, ey, ist das eine gute Idee.
Hat man dann festgestellt, es ist eine gute Idee, man könnte einfach auf eine CPU zwei CPUs bauen, zwei Kerne setzen.
Und erst dann kam das so eigentlich richtig auf, dass man die Software auch so programmieren musste, dass sie mehrere Kerne ausgenutzt hat. Früher war das easy. Früher hast du eine Software nicht wirklich großartig parallel programmieren müssen.
Du hast quasi einen riesen Loop in Main gehabt, da wurde alles gemacht und gut ist und das lief von CPU-Generation zu CPU-Generation immer schneller, weil sich die Taktraten erhöht haben.
und als sie dann irgendwann auf die Idee gekommen sind, aha, ja, hier Multithreading mehrere Kerne,
da musstest du wirklich, wenn du die ausnutzen wolltest, musstest du dann wirklich anfangen zu sagen,
okay, wie können wir die Arbeit denn wirklich echt parallelisieren, also können wir sagen,
okay, wir machen vielleicht, wir splitten das Array in zwei Hälften und sortieren es unabhängig voneinander
oder sowas, konntest du dann sagen.
Und dann mussten sich die Softwareentwickler
erst zu diesem Zeitpunkt Gedanken drüber machen,
ey, wie parallelisiert man
eigentlich wirklich
Software? Wie macht man das?
Vorher war das nicht notwendig.
Und da ist einem dann irgendwann auch aufgefallen,
ey, Software
aufzusplitten, sodass
sie quasi
Arbeitseinheiten hat, die wirklich echt
parallel laufen können,
ist gar nicht so einfach.
Und es ist gar nicht so einfach,
Nur weil man theoretisch mit zwei Kernen doppelt so viel Rechenleistung hat, die auch praktisch abzurufen.
So, und dann ging das eine ganze Weile.
Die Taktraten sind immer noch ein bisschen hochgegangen.
CPU-Kerneanzahl ist hochgegangen.
Alfred, danke schön für den Zap.
Kerneanzahl ist hochgegangen.
Und irgendwann, so vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit, ist man dann drauf gekommen, okay, das geht aber auch nicht mehr weiter.
wir geraten jetzt nicht nur an so thermische Limits, sondern wir geraten jetzt langsam auch an das, was, wie nennt man das denn dann, mechanisch, also was fertigungstechnisch machbar ist.
Also sprich, die Strukturen auf den CPUs werden zu klein und man kriegt da immer mehr Effekte rein, die man nicht haben will.
und das ist auch hauptsächlich der Grund, warum sich die letzten Jahre über die Hardwareentwicklung
nicht mehr so schnell anfühlt wie früher und das Gefühl ist auch richtig.
Also wenn man das vergleicht, ich habe eine CPU von 2022, 13.900K, das Ding war damals absolut High End
und wisst ihr was, 3,5 Jahre später ist das Ding immer noch nicht absolut High End,
aber immer noch eine der schnellsten CPUs.
Eineinhalb Jahre später.
Hätte sich früher kaputt gelacht drüber.
Früher musste es je nach aller aller aller spätestens zwei Jahre neuen Rechner kaufen,
komplett neue Ausstattung,
dass die Sachen überhaupt noch ordentlich gestartet sind.
Ich weiß, ich habe damals versucht, auf meinem zwei Jahre alten Rechner Far Cry zu spielen.
Der Rechner hat dann ungefähr sowas hier gemacht.
Und hatte keinen Bock drauf.
Das würde ich so pauschal nicht sagen.
Also ich denke, wir haben heute oftmals tatsächlich ein Problem mit Software, die nicht ordentlich optimiert ist.
Software, die nicht mehr richtig durchdacht wird und sowas.
Das hat aber natürlich mehrere Gründe und es hat natürlich auch ein paar Vorteile, wie das heute läuft. Also, Gründe ist natürlich, dass Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit heute ein sehr wichtiger Faktor ist, weil man ja genug Hardwareleistung hat.
Anders, da kann man nicht erklären, warum Software heute so oft ein verpackter Browser ist.
Ja, irgendwelche Elektron-Geschichten, wo du dann einen Text-Editor hast, der 2 GB RAM braucht.
Oder reicht das überhaupt?
Da drinnen kann man halt schnell Software entwickeln, die auch noch auf mehreren Plattformen ohne große Code-Anpassungen läuft.
Also Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit ist natürlich ein ganz entscheidender Faktor.
Den hätten die Leute damals auch schon gerne gehabt, ja, aber in Zeiten von 16 MB RAM und sowas, da war es halt ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, ey, scheiß drauf, wir machen da einfach mal 5 Abstraktionen drüber, das wird schon irgendwie funktionieren.
Er hätte damals keinen Mensch benutzt, weil es nicht richtig gelaufen wäre.
Ich rechne damals, ob der Nein zu Cyberpunk sagt. Damals hat noch keiner zu Far Cry, ich rede von Far Cry 1, da hat noch keiner an Cyberpunk gedacht.
Und Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit ist denke ich auch ein wichtiger Faktor
Ich fange jetzt nicht an mit AI dazu und sonst was
Aber gerade wenn man sich moderne Spiele-Engines oder sowas anguckt
Das ist natürlich schon Wahnsinn
Was heutzutage ein einzelner Entwickler bauen kann
an grafischer Qualität und auch Content in Spielen.
Das wäre früher nahezu undenkbar gewesen.
Bestes Beispiel dafür, Rollercoaster Tycoon,
das in großer Teilen in Assembler programmiert,
dass das ordentlich schnell lief.
Ich glaube, Rollercoaster Tycoon ist eines der größten
iiq 5 head spiele die entwickelt wurden also vom vom source code her
das musste er aber damals machen dass das ordentlich läuft
ja und jetzt hat man halt festgestellt okay jetzt hat man probleme jetzt kann man nicht
mehr cpu takt machen man kann noch nicht mal wirklich so viel mehr cpu kerne machen
Das ist von der Temperatur problematisch und es ist auch von den Strukturen her problematisch.
Deswegen faken die ja mittlerweile auch.
Also wenn irgendein...
Ich weiß nicht, was CPU-Hersteller gerade sagen, welchen Fertigungsprozess sie haben.
Chat, was sagen die aktuell?
Was ist so der aktuelle Fertigungsprozess bei Intel?
Was sagen die? 8 Nanometer?
Ich weiß es gar nicht, was die aktuell...
Zumindest ist das eh gelogen.
Ähm
Die, diese
Fertigungsprozess-Nanometer-Angabe
Bei CPUs hat mit der Realität
Meistens gar nichts mehr zu tun
Die sagen 8 Nanometer, das meiste davon
Ist gar nicht 8 Nanometer
Die labern einfach nur
War das nicht
Quake 3 mit diesem
Äh
Inverse Square Root Zeug, der schon auch zu Tode analysiert wurde auf YouTube.
Ja, ja, das war richtig krass früher.
Wenn man sich teilweise anguckt, wenn man sich Super Nintendo Spiele anguckt,
was da für Tricks
teilweise gelaufen sind.
Die haben ja, das muss man
jetzt vielleicht mal
sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Also,
der Super Nintendo,
dieses Ding hier,
mir geht es jetzt gar nicht mehr drum,
was das für Hardware-Specs hatte,
also von 1990.
Die Dinger, diese Konsolen,
die hat man ja an einem Fernseher betrieben.
An einem Röhrenfernseher.
So, und
Röhrenfernseh.
Das lief ja so.
Du hattest vorne
eine Schicht auf dem Fernseh, so ein bisschen
mit, weiß ich nicht, was ist das?
Phosphormäßiges, irgendwas, was
zumindest, wenn es mit einem Elektronenstrahl anschießt,
leuchtet. Ja? Die Pixelphosphorschicht
hattest du vorne auf dem
Fernseh drauf. Und hinten
hattest du quasi einen
Elektronenstrahl, der den
Bildschirm abgefahren hat.
Ah, du hast einen Elektronenstrahl, der den Bildschirm abgefahren hat von links oben.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie ist denn der gefahren?
Ist der so gefahren?
Oder ist der...
Ich glaube, der ist so gefahren, ne?
Der ist so gefahren immer.
So.
Und dann irgendwann...
Dann irgendwann war der hier unten.
Und dann hat er wieder oben angefangen.
So.
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Die Five Head Entwickler vom Super Nintendo und auch vom NES und sowas, die haben damals extra Berechnungen gemacht in der Zeit, die der Elektronenstrahl oder besser gesagt halt diese Steuerung für den Elektronenstrahl braucht, um von unten rechts sich wieder nach oben links zu resetten.
Also quasi die Zeit zwischen dem Aufhören des Bildrefreshs und dem Anfangen des Bildrefreshs.
Haben die genutzt, um extra Sachen zu berechnen, damit es überhaupt noch geht.
Damit es überhaupt alles dargestellt werden kann.
Und ich...
Ja, also ganz abgedreht.
Es gibt da Videos zu auf YouTube,
wie diese Sachen damals optimiert wurden.
Das ist wirklich komplett abgedreht,
was die sich da manchmal aus den Fingern gesaugt haben,
dass die Sachen überhaupt liefen auf den alten Konsolen.
Oder halt auch auf PCs damals.
Ja, genau, genau.
Horizontal Sync, Vertical Sync.
Genau. Das, ja, ja.
Das wird bestimmt. Und wenn der
Strahl rübergewandert ist, dann kannst du ja auch noch was
berechnen.
Und, und, ähm, damals gab es ja auch noch das Problem zwischen PAL und NTFS.
Heutzutage kann sich das keiner mehr vorstellen, ja.
Heute machen wir eigentlich immer volle Bilder.
Äh, nicht NTFS, äh, NTSC.
Ups.
Äh, heute haben wir immer komplette Bilder.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, es war so, NTSC waren 480 Zeilen, also 480p war das.
und
hatte
60 Hertz, ne?
War das?
Ach ne, genau.
Genau, 480, so war das.
Genau, 480i,
es war ja interlaced.
Stimmt, es war ja interlaced.
Es wurden ja immer nur die zweiten.
Genau, NTSC war 480i,
60 Hertz und
PAL war 567
i50 Hertz.
Das heißt, dann hattest du Spiele,
die liefen auf
in Europa, liefen die einfach
langsamer.
Dementsprechend waren bestimmt manche Spiele sogar
einen Ticken einfacher, wenn du sie
in Europa gespielt hast, als
wenn du sie in den USA gespielt hast. Oder ich glaube
Japan. Hat Japan nicht auch noch NTSC?
Generell sehen diese alten Spiele nicht so geil aus auf LCD-Monitoren.
Es gibt aber ganz gute Filter, die das ein bisschen nachstellen.
Dann sieht es ganz okay aus.
Ja, so, jetzt haben wir hier Computer-History ein bisschen geschwätzt.
Ich werde noch was trinken.
Ah.
Okay, Leute.
Ich glaube,
ich habe jetzt fast
4,5 Stunden geschwätzt.
Ich glaube, ich höre jetzt auf.
Nicer
Random-Stream.
Aber
4,5 Stunden
komplett durchschwätzen. Ich merke es schon
im Hals. Ich habe echt keine Ahnung,
wie das manche Streamer hinkriegen.
Die streamen irgendwie 12 Stunden
oder so am Stück und können am anderen
Tag noch ordentlich reden.
Gut, die labern auch nicht 12 Stunden
komplett durch.
Die spielen dann irgendwas oder zeigen irgendwas und so
Und labern nicht ohne Punkt und Komma
Vier Stunden
Aber trotzdem weiß ich nicht, wie die das auf die Reihe kriegen
Chat haben wir irgendjemanden, den wir hosten können?
Irgendwas? Irgendwen?
Wir gucken mal kurz
Twitch
Ähm
Da einer was streamt
Ah, ich hauste keinen.
Habt ihr nicht das letzte Mal gesagt,
ähm,
das
war für die meisten
nix?
Obwohl ich da selbst nichts dazu sagen kann.
Ich habe mich da letztes Mal auf eure Empfehlungen verlassen.
Ich gucke dafür die Videos ab und zu mal ganz gerne.
Das ist ja der, der auch die Linux-Kernel-Engineers-Fixes-Bugs und sowas hochlädt.
Man kommt...
Oh, fuck, du hast recht.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich wollte schon ewig neue Emotes und Sub-Badges und alles machen.
Aber das nächste Mal dann.
Kappa.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sehen uns spätestens...
Sonntagmorgen.
Aufwachen, streamen.
Morgen muss ich arbeiten.
Ich hab nicht frei. Habt ihr morgen frei?
Oder müsst ihr arbeiten?
Okay, ich muss morgen arbeiten.
Aber ich mach Homeoffice. Ich fahr nicht nach Frankfurt.
Wartungsfenster heute Nacht.
Copy Fail? Dirty Frack?
Oder was halt musst du Wartungsfenstern?
oder sagt bloß Windows.
Monk HW.
Ach, ESP geht uns.
Also Netzwerk-Kram.
Okay.
Ein GLHF.
Okay, Leute.
Wir hören uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Wem der Stream gefallen hat, übrigens kann man an der Stelle auch noch ein Follow dalassen.
Würde mich auch freuen. Bis dann.
Macht's gut. See you.